That's everything to me.
See that on the podcast.
What were you just saying?
Young Tony Hinchcliffe.
I love fanny packs and I've been using
them continuously.
Yeah,
that's right.
Folks,
don't get scared that the Illuminati and
the elite,
they want to keep you from embracing the
fanny pack.
They want to.
They want to emasculate you.
It's probably not them.
That's like some group name.
You've heard of the rat pack where the
fanny pack.
Brian's never dared one.
Oh yeah,
I have yours,
but I wear it all the time.
Never seen more,
but you know,
it's cool it.
So there's little ones that stretch.
Have you ever seen those?
Like super small and they like stretch
big.
So you could put like a couple of things
in it or nothing.
Nothing.
And you can't really see it.
Yeah.
Those things are good for jogging the
they,
they pulled tight to you.
It's a smaller pocket though.
Can't see.
The thing with these things is if you
travel as much as we do,
you just have all your shit in that
thing and you just drop it off.
Just take any thought out of your head
you might have about getting laid.
That won't be happening.
If you are a single person,
you're a single man.
Single girl could pull it off.
We don't give a fuck.
Pennypack would not make her any less
hot.
No need to put a condom in a fanny pack.
You'll never use it.
Your fanny pack though isn't really
cheesy or anything.
It's actually cool looking.
It's root slim.
It's.
We sell them.
They put a higher primate logo on it.
Roots does,
but it's a roots fanny pack.
They are the ones that dice was wearing.
That's how I found out about it.
Dice came in and I had instant fanny
pack envy.
I was like,
what do you have here?
What do you have?
Oh,
this is the one I got
when I'm in the line at Tsa.
I eyeball everybody that's emptying
their pockets and I just look at
everybody and then I get snap and drop
it like a mic into the things that
everybody just saw me
and it zips up.
Your pockets don't zip up.
It's better.
Everything falls out of pockets on an
airplane.
There's something about it
I've worn on stage maybe four times.
You've worn it on word,
on stage in Utah.
It gets in the way though.
Flopping around.
You're moving too much.
Yeah.
There's certain places where I.
I can't wear a fanny pack in one way it
would work because if you actually moved
it to your fanny and there's just
something about that.
That's not gonna happen.
If you're going to have a fanny pack,
it's got to be in the front
and waterproof.
Broader proof.
Fanny packs might be next.
Why not?
Shower with soap in there.
Pull it out.
If you have like a secret and you keep
it in that fanny pack,
so I a picture of your deck or something
like that.
You don't want anybody having an actual
physical picture was the one body Kelly
always had,
was wearing.
It was like when I went over your
shoulder roll a Bandolero.
What is it?
It's like a fanny pack that's on your
chest.
It's like for people who are scared of
wearing a fanny packs or they pretend
they're world travelers with skinny
souls.
You know those dudes who were like suede
shoes of muted colors with thin soles,
you know those kind of guys and they
have like skinny on and then they were
like a Satchel.
I have a Satchel.
I just got back from winning and size.
It's amazing.
These time of year.
Yeah.
That guy works.
Not sure.
I like to take those people,
satchels from them and just wear them
around my waist.
She just turned my Satchel into a fanny
pack.
It's more of a butcher's apron.
Yeah.
There's something about them.
They,
for whatever reason,
not only do they not catch on,
they became gross.
Like fanny packs are gross.
They're way more than didn't catch on
this actual,
oh,
this man is very involved in unicef and
the Red Cross.
He goes to foreign lands and the
liberties.
Malaria medicine
ready?
Look at that guy do a uhg.
There's something about you.
When I'm not on the Big Bang theory,
I carry randomly Satchel.
I had a blow a guy to get this rule.
What's in that size?
We're just a bunch of Dicks,
just pubic hair and it's filled with
com.
Thirteen pounds of this when he walks.
All right.
How much,
how much do you think it would wave?
That was filled with come?
How heavy is
thicker than water?
So probably about nine pounds.
Gallon of milk.
Nine pounds.
Why should know?
I've,
I've seen an lms.
We had pitchers of come on.
Fear factor was actual pictures.
What kind of come it was donkey Kong.
Oh yeah.
Doc,
he comes the cheapest you can get
because donkeys are hybrids and they're
not viable.
So that donkey comes just useless.
When you had that much come,
did it separate?
Like was there like a tough to blend it?
No,
he didn't have to shake it like a
lemonade curdle at the top.
Scoop off.
No,
no,
you didn't have to shake it.
I know what you're talking about.
Some of those energy drinks,
even vixen,
uh,
you know,
water bottle and then it settles to the
bottom.
You got no comments.
Just come.
It's basically Cox not.
There it is.
Oh no,
those girls,
one of them drank a glass of calm and
one drank a glass of urine.
It's the what?
Like there's two times ever doing that
show where I was,
where I was like,
what in the fuck are you doing?
Like you can't do this.
Like you guys are going too far.
Oh,
she's that donkey.
Donkey come a whole bigger mug full of
donkey.
Come God,
I missed somebody sat down and did this,
this,
this is how crazy this show was.
Somebody sat down,
said,
I got an idea.
It started pitching that people would
have to drink donkey come.
It puts my mind that it was on NBC.
Yeah,
and then other people said,
yeah,
the,
the.
I like what you're saying.
Makes Sense.
Let's do it.
NBC is as mainstream as it gets.
Like,
Hey,
after you're done enjoying donkey,
come watch the nightly news with Tom
Brokaw as mainstream as possible.
And the girl it,
she's
pretending like she didn't love it
though.
She liked it.
Ugh.
It's not even her first time drinking
donkeys.
Who?
It was so ridiculous at the shit.
I would love to abstain.
Ridiculous show.
So silly.
That's overkill.
Like being able to look at the donkey.
Oh God.
I love it.
You're just yelling at these guys,
come on,
chug it.
That guy just shucked it so quick.
They're hugging on each other.
So strange.
It just.
Then they get to throw up.
They have to hold it in their mouth for
like a few seconds or something.
His buddies up and he didn't even drink
it.
I don't need to relive this.
We can stop now.
So unnecessary.
Incredible.
It's just amazing that that was an
actual show.
No,
it was.
It's amazing.
As amazing to me as it is anybody that
was watching it.
It doesn't even feel like it was me.
I watch it now and even though I know it
was me and I'm like,
I didn't do that.
It's crazy because most shows like for
comedians to host suck and aren't fun at
all.
You know what I mean?
But eat that show seems like it was.
You were surprised.
Like it's like you get to watch it.
You're like,
oh,
we're making these people drink donkey.
Come today.
Like,
how do you not enjoy that?
It's hard.
It's hard to drink to help these people.
You've got to root them on.
Out of all the things on fear factor,
did you ever like sample anything like
dip your finger in anything and try it
or.
Yeah,
eat a bunch of shit.
The first episode I felt bad.
The people that eat sheep's eyeball,
so I said I went to just for a goof,
but I don't even think we put that on
camera.
I just said I'll do it for you.
Did it tastes because the sheep shit.
You fucking can't help yourself.
You literally can't help yourself.
No,
it didn't taste that bad.
It was not that big a deal.
It's more of in your head than anything.
I ate a tomato horn worm again.
All in your head.
The actual taste and now that I'm not
that big a deal.
Those were the big ones.
The juicy.
Yeah.
It exploded in my mouth.
Didn't,
didn't taste bad at all.
It's like nothing.
I'm cockroach.
I had a big ass cockroach.
What was that?
Madagascar hissing cockroach.
Was it alive?
Well,
there was a young lady that was on the
show and she was going to get kicked off
if she didn't do something else.
Like she had to do something to stay in
the show.
It was all for charity.
Right.
So because it was a celebrity fear
factor out.
Alison Sweeney,
I believe her name is from days of our
lives and uh,
so I said,
look,
if you eat one of these,
a roach,
I don't know who came up with this idea,
someone in the,
the office,
she's,
I'm like,
if eat one of these roaches you can
stay.
And she said,
uh,
I can't even roach.
I go,
what about a worm?
what about two worms?
I think we made a deal like she maybe
she ate two worms or something like that
and I had to eat a roche.
So stupid.
It's just such a ridiculous show.
But anyway,
the point is there's,
this roach tasted like nothing is.
Nothing
made me cough because
although I was kind of put all the
little legs and the parts and stuff,
why would you do that?
You love it.
That's hilarious.
What Baldwin brother?
The Baldwin brother,
Steven.
It's nice guy.
Very nice guy.
I would have loved to have seen one.
He did.
Yeah.
He Won.
Who's funny,
dude?
He's.
Oh,
you know,
put the Jesus though.
He's with pro Jesus all.
All.
All up with Jesus.
Wow.
Yeah,
he's like a big Jesus like a
proselytizer does like retreats and shit
or something like that.
Very Jesus oriented individual,
but a happy guy.
Very nice guy.
Yeah.
Kirk Cameron style?
No,
not that far.
No.
Kurt cameras in some wacky place where
they look at a banana and they go,
this has to be a sign of God.
Look how the banana fits in your hand.
It is the perfect shape.
Note how appeals designed by the Creator
himself to fit in your hand.
So if you ever seen that ray comfort
explains a banana.
We gotta watch this because this is his
boy.
Like these two guys.
They get together and they don't fuck.
They just looked at each other and they
want to and no one does anything and
they just keep doing it night after
night.
It just talk about Jesus and stare into
each other's eyes,
but this is his buddy that he baldwins.
No,
no,
no.
The other one.
Kurt Cameron.
Oh,
this is his buddy.
It's like off the deep end.
Jesus guy,
and this is the guy that he holds up a
fucking banana and it's the atheist
nightmare.
He says.
He's like,
this is a banana in it is the atheist
atheist's nightmare study a well
wellmade.
You'll find on the fast side of ridges
on the close side,
two ridges.
If you get your hand ready to grip it
around,
you'll find on the far side,
there were three groups on the close
side,
two groups,
but banana and the hand off perfectly
made one or the other.
You'll find a maker of a banana or
almighty God has made it with a nonslip
surface.
Has Al would indicate,
is it England contents green too early.
Yellow.
Just right.
Black,
too late.
Have you go to the top of the banana?
You'll find as with a soda can make us.
They placed a tab at the top,
so God has placed a tab at the top.
When you pull the tab,
the contents don't squirt in your face.
You'll find a wrapper which is
biodegradable,
has perforations.
Notice how gracefully it sensitivity.
Human hand notice has appointed the top
for ease of entry,
just the right shape.
The human mouth,
it's Chewy,
easy to digest,
has even curved or the face to make the
whole process so much easier.
Seriously,
curt,
the creation
testifies to the genius of God's
creative writing was about to jump in.
Oh,
you just totally made sense.
What you said wasn't fucking ridiculous
at.
Oh,
look how Jesus designed this banana.
Is that.
Get us kicked off youtube.
We're going to have to edit that out.
We're gonna have to edit it out.
Yeah,
most likely.
It's not our content and we don't want
to get booted off Youtube,
but I'm ray comfort banana.
Google it.
It's an awesome God.
It's awesome.
All the gods shit to the side like it is
sort of crazy.
If you think about fruits,
how amazing they are.
Like it's like trick candy and a rapper
already,
you know?
Well,
it's a.
it's like a delivery system trick.
It's like there are seeds inside these
plants and if you eat it,
it goes through your body,
you shit it out.
So it like literally comes with manure,
like it's got a seed,
it's got some manure,
it's got shit to the seed,
can grow in.
It's like literally comes out with
fertilizer.
There's a way,
especially with like animals like
undulates,
like cows and stuff like that.
Like they're shitting out like almost
like mulch.
They're shitting out compost mean they,
you take cows shit and you take that
shit and you grow things with it.
I mean it's a great fertilizer.
People use it on their crops,
so it's in a lot of ways I would
imagine.
This is just me thinking that this is
what it is,
is like some sort of a like a
transportation device for seeds.
Right?
Doesn't that make sense?
It's crazy.
I never thought of it that way though.
They're like,
animals eat the seeds and then they,
they're pooping out the next thing.
It's don't have seeds.
No,
don't.
They don't do that.
If it was really Jesus as if it was
really an atheist nightmare,
I think there'd be seeds seedless
beautiful.
If bananas at seeds,
they'd be bunk.
Man Fits into math.
Perfect.
I wonder that dummy knows that we've
actually like changed the shape of
bananas.
Go,
go.
We're going to wild banana.
Those little scrubby ass bitch ass
bananas.
So it's not like those Dole Bananas,
those big whopper bananas were like
cheese.
Those Gmo Bananas.
Even steroids to like a 10 year old's
arm.
Like these Gmo bananas are fucking
ridiculous.
The Brock Lesnar Bananas.
Yeah.
Tell that to ray comfort.
He doesn't understand agriculture.
Silly.
Fuck the way Jesus made this benign.
He's incredible.
He's just such a strange argument,
but it's just.
If that's what you want to believe.
If you really want to believe that God
designed a banana so perfectly to let
you know that it's food.
Explain coconuts.
Coconuts are fucking awesome for you.
It's so hard to get to them.
You've got to chop through that hoskin.
Pull away all that bullshit that's on
the outside climate.
Huge tree.
First.
You get a crack them open and then you
gotta you gotta take the milk out and
the meat you got like scoop the meat of
it and if you want to get the oil all
you want to take all that coconut and
turn it into coconut oil.
Oh,
what a pain.
That Dick.
That's gonna be.
Yeah.
Have you seen the certain foods that are
going to get more and more expensive
because of global warming and stuff like
that.
Like the price of chocolate and the
price of coffee is just going to go
through the roof.
Pistachios I guess this year or like
we're like on a shortage.
So you're going to see like pistachios,
like double in price in the next couple
months.
It's really weird.
Like what foods are on the endangered
species list almost.
Maybe we shouldn't live in a place
that's really fucking hot right now when
the earth is getting hotter.
Yeah.
I mean what the fuck is la going to be
like?
La is going to be like Phoenix,
right?
Like Phoenix is like a bump hotter than
La.
Definitely.
When you say a lot like a bump,
a good solid bump,
but everything's shifted.
Earthquakes,
hurricanes,
everything's kind of like Oklahoma had
an earthquake the other day,
but that's because of fracking.
Yeah.
That is a.
That is no joke,
man.
They're having.
They're having so many earthquakes
because of fracking.
I think Oklahoma just put some.
They put a pause.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's a pause on drilling
new wells or it's a pause on.
It can't be a pause and operating the
wells.
I think it is.
I think it was like 41 different
fracking sites.
Let's find out what it is.
July me.
They're going crazy with fracking.
Ohio has been doing it and they've been
getting earthquakes.
It's crazy.
It's like we get most of the oil now I
guess from the.
From earth here,
from America.
Oklahoma orders shut down of 37 wells
after earthquake.
Fuck man.
Ooh,
that's crazy.
Good Lord.
Then there's been like the Iraqi look,
a hot.
This girl is telling you the news.
That's the new thing isn't really super
hot.
Has this like supermodel lady.
She's beautiful.
Have you ever seen the Fox News girls?
They're all like seven feet tall.
I listened to her,
but let's watch her face move that
they're just getting the hottest women.
That Mexican weather girl with the but
oh my God,
I've seen that lady love her.
That's ridiculous.
But that's kind of like a gimmick,
right?
And that's Mexico.
What's this?
A CNN like?
This is.
They're just hiring the best looking
people.
Yeah.
You for sexy
light skin,
black check.
Beautiful.
And she's talking to this man,
will I believe in Jesus and Jesus wants
us to dig oil.
Look at my tie.
Look at my haircut.
It's conservative as is my approach to
language.
Ma'Am.
You won't hear me using any forbidden
words.
You know,
we need to keep the oil prices low.
The way to keep the oral process flow is
to continue safe and ethical fracking.
And that's what we're going to do.
Meanwhile,
get back to the hot chick.
Let me see her faith.
You don't get to see it.
What the fuck are they doing?
Like all these shows like Fox News and
all the there.
There's,
there's gotta be something to like the
fact that propaganda being delivered by
someone who is so hot.
You just want to stare him like those.
Those Fox ice queens.
Totally.
There's a bunch of them that are just
like,
they're so hot.
You just want to look at their face like
little kids get compelled to look at
pretty women's faces.
Fox News has a bunch of stuff
strategically to keep you watching,
like spinning things and it's all like.
It's all mental dude.
We were watching once and who was it?
Was it the Megan Kelly lady that was
crossing and uncrossing your legs like
30 fucking times and she's wearing this
little skirt.
Find out.
It might not have been her.
It might've been one of those other
hotties that was high as other Fox
hotties,
but it was ridiculous because she's
wearing literally like she's got a
Napkin over vagina.
It's a small napkin.
I mean it's not as much of a skirt at
all.
She has these super long legs and high
heels on and she's doing this.
She should she have a little Bush
because you see her.
No,
you don't get a chance to say she's
very,
very calculated,
but if I was staying with a dude who
moved his legs that much,
I'd be like,
Bro,
you okay?
Why keep crossing your legs are fucking
cricket.
You're trying to sing me a song.
You see that?
You see the girl that was twerking in
her butt popped up in her underwear?
Yes.
Fox News.
I don't think that's related.
Brian watches.
Fox News.
Fox News is hurting.
So I keep hearing Fox News is hurting.
I watched routers and uh,
who was it that was saying that they had
heard?
Fuck,
I'm trying to remember who was telling
me this.
Was it you?
Will you telling me the thing about a
trump and a television network?
It was trying to remember what,
where I heard it and it was,
I think it was a radio show or
something,
but that there's a lot of those,
a lot of people use added like Sean
Hannity and I think that God has taken
over his campaign that used to run fox
or taken over his spot and I don't know
how they're going to transition.
If he loses,
but that trump news channel is going to
be started up next year,
the end of this year,
trump news,
24 hour trump.
Here's what he does.
If he's.
If he was smart,
I mean he's obviously smart,
not right.
He's obviously really good at making
money.
He's obviously,
well,
whatever you can say about the
outrageous shit that he says,
that guy's ridiculously successful.
Ridiculously right.
I mean,
yeah,
his dad gave him a big loan to start out
with,
but what the fuck ever at the end of the
day,
that guy's ridiculous.
Ridiculously successful.
If he wanted to open a good television
cable network and use that as a platform
to set them up for four years from now,
10,
like the kind of fucking shit that he
would say about Hillary and like other
candidates that no one would have the
balls to say like he takes it to this
non political place.
You know,
like he insults Hillary Clinton all the
time.
He calls her crooked Hillary.
Has there ever been to presidential
candidates or one of them had nicknames
for all the other people?
Now he's a genius.
He made fun of everybody,
Lion,
Ted,
who was,
keeps repeating it,
and it becomes like it's.
That's who she is.
That's crooked hillary.
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
It's amazing what he did.
If she just started calling him like
Orange Donald or something,
it'd be Keller.
She could really fire back.
She needs a little like roast help
because he's digging in deep.
It's not just that there's an
uncomfortable sound that she makes when
she speaks,
when she gives speeches,
they're not soothing and they don't draw
you in like as much as she is way more
qualified to be a leader than he is.
Right.
He knows way more about foreign policy.
Knows way more about how Washington
works.
She's deep,
right?
Like she'd be a way more qualified
leader.
There's something about the quality of
voice she needs to drink.
Some donkey come.
Which by the way is like the end.
Isn't that the democratic.
Think you're going to jail for that.
That's the democratic.
Uh,
I liked her just because she at least
has built the deck,
not billing anymore,
man.
He's bill enough.
Bills stay.
He's,
he's kind of
the stand back and take naps in the
background guy.
Now if you noticed that there was a
speech he was giving,
he was falling asleep in the middle of
the speech and you know,
he just in really poor health,
apparently his body's just not doing so
well.
That's what happens when the blowjob
stop.
Wow.
You can't have fun anymore.
You just can't help yourself.
I mean,
it's true.
He was a machine back in the day and now
just came too much.
It's all dried out.
Hi.
Ya know,
just dried out to shut
so many loads.
Poor guy.
Um,
well he was a two term president.
I wouldn't say poor guy.
He was the best guy.
Made a mad run for it.
Mean regardless of all the Dick pulling
out and all that stuff.
He's a madman.
Would you expect from madman?
He's doing some mad man type shit.
All I remember is everybody was taking
vacations,
owning houses and gas prices were like
forty five cents a gallon.
Right?
So,
I mean he should.
I don't know enough.
I don't know enough about the economic
cycles,
but I do know that the people that are
smart that talk about it say that
there's like these upturns and downturns
that you can almost calculate that just
is going to happen and then we have a
weird economy and that these people that
are the experts,
they can kind of predict how things
start happening and deregulation moves
things along a little bit and this moves
things along.
Tax Incentive moves things a little
long,
a little further,
but then somewhere along the line the
house of cards comes falling down and
they,
um,
they see the big one was the mortgage
crisis of 2008.
We avoided an even bigger one with the
commercial real estate crisis.
There were,
there were saying that they were worried
about that more than anything because if
you drive down like any place in the
valley,
just go drive down the valley and look
at all the buildings for sale.
Look at all the buildings for lease.
It's,
it's way more than you used to say.
Like as you're driving down,
you see available for re release
available for sale,
available,
available.
You see available like all over the
fucking place.
Like that
could fall apart too,
man.
Apparently that's a big one.
Apparently there's like a lot of people
that are like leveraging all these
commercial properties and moving things
around,
selling things here.
But there's a lot of vacant office shit.
Well there's like this whole like flip
your house movement to,
you know,
in those channels.
Like when I'm at hotels and stuff,
he ended up,
I ended up sticking on it like that.
Like trying to convince everybody that
they can just go buy a house and flip it
and sell it.
Make money.
It's so easy.
Look,
he just come in,
tear down a wall and then sell it for
twice as much more.
Yeah.
Their character.
There's two,
right?
They're all like,
I'm going to do my own grout out there,
laying tiles and shit.
Right.
And then they edit it down and make it
look like it took 12 seconds on TV.
This old house,
you remember that.
That was one of my favorite shows
growing up with Bob Vila.
That's pretty much the original flipping
houses show,
but they made it a whole story on this
went on for days.
What happened to Bob Vila see alive?
That's a good question.
It is a good question.
I forgot about them like huge until he
was a hero.
Yeah.
This old house was done was like a giant
show,
or at least it was for me growing up
because we watched it every day.
That in the antique roadshow is another
one that had just love on pbs.
It was for me to still rocking.
That might be real 1 million followers.
It is.
Look it up.
Verified handsome bastard.
He looks exactly the senior AC coils
mean higher efficiency and lower energy
bills.
How clean are yours?
I just had that one of those air
conditioning's fucked me for life fucked
you because it has like a drain and it's
supposed to be tilted a little so it
could drip out.
Mine was dripping the other way,
like I didn't even know it was going
underneath my carpet,
so now it got underneath a to my wood
floors and now there's big buckles.
So when you walk it's like speed bumps
underneath my carpet and fun and there's
probably black mold in there and
probably go die.
Does that help with black mold is from
that,
right?
Like water,
it's
moisture from water damage,
but it has to be present,
you know,
and asked to be present and then it can
grow like a.
I know I'm,
well Tom Lucas was a big one because he
would talk about it on television or on
the radio rather like his,
his whole house had to be gutted,
like down to the studs that was in
Hollywood.
He's feeling like shit for years,
just like just health was poor,
just really didn't have any energy
trying to fill out what the fuck was
going on.
And um,
they brought in a black mold specialists
and they're like,
dude,
you're fucking houses infected.
So he's breathing in all these spores,
these black mold sports just being
poisoned all the time.
Did they have home tests for that?
I bet you anything.
I have so much black,
black matters people.
Fucking son of a bitch.
He's
got to keep an eye on it.
The jokes they come,
they just come.
Um,
yeah man.
I think um,
they,
they do a lot of testing for it.
You should probably get it checked out.
Some people have it,
man.
Do you ever ever seen one of Jim Norton?
Jim Norton was a gym and Bobby Jimmy and
Kelly lived in an
apartment and they had black mold on the
walls so bad that you would take the
picture off the wall and it was just
like,
you could see it all over behind the
picture.
It's probably isn't as common though in
Los Angeles since we're a desert and
everything's dry,
you know,
it's a good question.
I think if there's water,
like if you have water damage,
like say if you have a leaky pipe or
something like that for long periods of
time,
see that shit dripping down.
That's black mold juice hose lines.
Now Watch,
they pick up the uh,
it's um,
cribs.
Jim Norton is a,
if you want to find it as the video and
they say brace yourself so they push us
and the fucking wall is just covered
with black mold behind the photo.
I mean like someone spray painted all
over it.
I need a priest to come in and give an
extra systems of health.
How did it happen though?
Like what was you speaking?
They're slobs to fucking slobs.
Who knows?
Somebody might have come on that
picture.
You know,
it's Jim Norton.
Who the hell knows he's a savage.
Look at him playing chess.
Listen to cds.
That's pretty much your apartment.
Red Band Department.
Pretty much every comedian.
Ridiculous people.
Yeah.
That black molds.
No jokes.
Don't get it in your life.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
I keep an eye on all the black.
All the black mold.
Yeah.
It's um,
I don't think is there more than one
variety of black mold and does it have
to be like water damage for a long time?
Because I'm sure my carpet probably
dried out,
you know,
if I caught it could be,
could be.
I don't know enough.
I don't know,
you know,
I know,
uh,
that mold and spores thrive in moist
conditions,
you know,
like the forest but have no idea,
man.
It's creepy stuff.
That's creepy.
Yeah.
Fungus and mold and shit like that.
It's just so weird.
There's like these,
these lifeforms that live on life forms,
you know,
they like,
you leave her a pair,
leave it sitting around somewhere and
forget about it.
Come back in a couple of days and it's
got this little green civilization
growing on it.
Like who are you,
where'd you guys come from?
Like,
what are you doing here?
What would you.
Unlike the banana,
which has a skin that protects it from
these things because Jesus loves
bananas.
He gave him a southern accent and even
though he's from New Zealand,
interesting.
And it's interesting choice.
I hit a bunch of mold the other day late
at night and we bought strawberries,
you know,
like underneath the strawberry,
like green and stuff.
I had no idea because it was dark eating
strawberries and the next day I go in to
get some more and I'm like,
they're all moldy.
I'm like,
was I was reading moldy strawberry?
Yeah,
and the dark.
man.
It's probably not even that bad for you.
It's probably just all in your head.
I mean,
otherwise people would be dying left and
right,
right.
Because everybody eats strawberries and
doesn't pay attention or blueberries.
Blueberries.
They always fucking mold on on cheese.
Sometimes blueberries have mold.
Right?
Right.
When you buy them,
you buy them and bring them home.
You're like,
fuck.
You're already molding.
Yeah.
Trader Joe's a lot of times cheese to
eat,
a slice of cheese.
Not even
realize half of it's white and green.
Well,
some cheeses to you,
Brian.
Nobody else is eating Greens.
Will.
What were you leaving your cheese?
Remember?
My mom would always say,
just pull off the mold part and just,
you know,
it's still good.
I would if that's true.
Yeah,
but pull the cheese out of the glove
compartment and screen you're eating it.
I just don't think that the economy
mold that we're talking about as toxic.
I just bet it's not like Jamie lookup
mold on strawberries.
Is it?
Oh,
Katie Moldy food.
What was it say?
May cause may have visible bacteria
along with the mold.
Yes,
some old cause,
allergic reactions,
respiratory problems,
and a few molds in the right conditions.
Produce Mycotoxins,
poisonous substances that can make you
sick.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just Google strawberries,
moldy strawberry.
Can you eat mostly
strawberries?
Google can Brian,
red bandy,
moldy stressing.
You've done something like this before
to think of your fruit had mold and it's
just like,
I just bought this also.
So have you ate mode?
Also,
Joe,
I'm sure I have
quick answer.
The most likely result of eating moldy
fruit is absolutely nothing unless the
person eating the mold is allergic.
However,
while the majority of molds are not
dangerous,
moldy fruit is more likely to be spoiled
and spoiled fruit may cause illness
because mold may form on fruit without
the fruit spoiling.
Simply cutting the moldy area off is
also a solution.
Most molds are not harmful,
somewhere even beneficial.
In fact,
mold is actually a form of fungus
similar to mushrooms.
Mold grows and damp environments,
fruit skin,
blah,
blah.
Hmm.
Interesting.
I've always been scared of mold
fungus in general,
so freaky freaky organism because it's
not really a plant.
A fungus actually breathes in oxygen and
breathe out carbon dioxide and they say
it's closer to an animal that it is to a
plant in like what it is like what kind
of a being it is.
Very,
very bizarre.
Well,
a magic mushrooms does to the brain.
I mean there's definitely some stuff
going on there.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's what that feels like.
You're communicating with like a.
it's like you tap in through this
organism to this matrix of like,
not just like plant intelligence,
but the intelligence of the actual earth
itself.
It feels like almost like you're being
transmitted in a way where you can now
understand all these things that are
around you all the time,
but they're muted because he just,
he just lacked the ability to perceive
them.
Like the earth itself.
Like we walk around and we're like,
wow,
so pretty today,
but do you really.
You don't really feel what the earth is
the way you feel it when you're on
mushrooms.
When you're on mushrooms,
you like,
you feel the actual grass as like a type
of an organism.
There's a thing like this,
that grass,
it stops like a couple of leaves and
some dirt and some it,
and then it becomes instead this feeling
like you're,
you're connected to this like almost
like a,
like a circuit,
you know,
like a biological circuit.
That's what like a beautiful thick lawn
feels like when you're on mushrooms,
like when you're standing in it,
you feel like you're connected to this
very strange life form.
That is what it is.
That's not even a hallucinatory sort of
a feeling,
but I think pretty much everybody that
that does any sort of psychedelic plant
based,
psychedelic mushrooms,
animal base,
whatever you want,
call it,
fungus based.
You reach these weird places where you
go,
okay,
my talking to that thing that I eat,
that thing that thing's talking to me
now.
Like is it,
is it communicating with me?
Threw me digesting it?
Is that what's happening?
Is it.
Let me go into some strange dimension
when I eat it.
It is amazing.
I miss this year shroom fest.
That's normally the one time a year
where I do it.
We go out in the desert,
but I had like,
I was on the road or something and I
miss it,
man.
I'm overdue for one.
Like it's like it'll be so connected to
the universe and you feel it.
You feel,
you know,
you just try to remember what happened.
Like you try to stay in that,
but it goes away and it's amazing
because like you're out in the desert or
at least that's where I normally do it
and you're looking at the rocks and the
moon and the stars are just beaming out
there and you'll feel,
you know,
is lost in the universe has ever.
And then all of a sudden you'll hear
like one of your buddies Fart,
you know,
come back and laughed for 20 minutes
straight about it.
Yeah.
It's a very strange life form.
Very strange thing that you take into
your body that does that.
There's a gang of them too.
It's just so weird.
So I don't,
you know,
I don't,
I really don't know what's going on with
that.
Isn't it crazy that it comes from cow
poop?
Yeah.
Well that's where it grows,
but really come from it.
But it,
uh,
it grows really good on it because the,
the stomach of a cow against that double
onion,
you only make that stuff,
that manure.
It's just so rich for things to grow in
it.
So,
which I do the thing with my finger,
that's the kind of fucking we need to
grow these mushrooms.
Just a manure.
These counts your seat and Alfalfa all
day.
Alfalfa.
It's delicious.
Mushrooms grow.
When Duncan went to school,
Dunkin with the school and Super
Hippieville,
he uh,
he grew up in Asheville,
North Carolina,
which is a fucking great town.
Have you ever worked at Asheville?
Got to come with me to Asheville.
Asheville's fucking,
it's,
I almost don't want to tell people about
it because I don't want people moving
there and ruin it because it's like you
could walk around like it's a small town
but the people are cool as fuck.
Like,
and it's like a part of the community of
the College of the university and the
university,
super lefty,
like super hippies soup all like
Duncan's like living up there in the
mountains of North Carolina in like some
of the most beautiful landscape you're
ever going to see in your life.
Just out and out.
Amazing scenery,
incredible scenery.
And I love that.
There's still places like that.
Yeah,
like it's crazy.
Like my buddy little landy that the
glasses,
he's from South Carolina and he went
home to visit his family and he's
walking around the park with his mom and
Bill Murray is just sitting on a bench.
Where was this chillen wherever in South
Carolina where Bill Murray flips.
That's where he's from.
Two,
I thought Bill Murray
lived in like the up the upper,
uh,
on the what on the East River or one of
the rivers.
He lives like upstate New York.
Like there was a whole Anthony Bordain
episode about he lives like way the fuck
up.
They're up a river and maybe he was just
hanging out and because he lives in a
bunch of places.
Yeah.
Bill Marianthi.
Oh,
Charleston,
South Carolina.
Oh,
you know what?
That's right.
This was the new episode that he did.
He moved to a new place and Bill Murray
does not have a girlfriend.
He's like,
this dude.
yeah,
I'll just be by myself.
Just leave me alone,
please.
We're just going to go have my life.
He did this interview about.
It was talking about.
I was like,
I'm not really interested in all that.
Goes along with that.
He did it,
man.
He is the coolest ever.
He's a great,
great representative of cool.
The leader of the real ghost busters.
They killed him in the new movie.
The new ghostbusters movie.
They kill Bill Murray.
They can go kill themselves because I've
never watched it.
He's a bad guy.
I didn't really kill him.
He's a skeptic.
He.
It's like the whole thing.
It's very,
very.
What?
It's what it's like.
It's like what my point was about
Asheville is that there were so many
kids getting high off mushrooms off of
these cows because they're up in this
farm area and it's raining all the time
and everything's wet as fuck.
It's lush and green and these mushrooms
just grew like weeds everywhere and it
was so bad that they had to give the
cows food,
that special food that made their,
their manure so that the mushrooms,
if they did grow in them,
they wouldn't be potent.
Yeah,
it wouldn't.
It wouldn't work.
I remember when we were in college would
go to certain places and get trash bags
worth of mushrooms because some areas
just because of the weather and the
farms and stuff like that,
it just grew mushrooms like crazy.
You've got to be so careful though with
mushrooms,
like what you're taking,
like if you think it's one kind of
mushroom,
but it's another kind of mushroom.
There's some mushrooms that'll kill you
in seconds.
That happened recently on this old folks
home.
These,
uh,
these old folks were hanging out and
this lady went out and gathered up.
Some mushrooms should probably out
fucking head on,
you
know,
what kind of Alzheimer's medicine or
anything they give them.
Like when you're in old folks homes,
dude,
they will throw some pills down your
throat.
Oh yeah.
Like you,
you get to choose how fucked up you want
to be all day and so there's ladies out
there picking mushrooms and just got a
gang of poison once,
cooked them all up for everybody to.
Everybody died.
Yeah.
Whoa.
She cooked him at the old folks' home.
Brought them back.
Yeah.
She cooked him for the old folks at the
old folks' home.
Just whack the whole crew.
Yeah.
I don't remember how many people died,
but it was more than one.
Do you hear about all these people dying
for elderly women die for people sick
and after eating white wild mushrooms.
Yeah.
So crazy shit here about all those
people dying from heroin overdoses
because there was a bad batch of heroin
in like Ohio or something and like 41
people I've overdosed on like the same
heroin.
I did hear about that.
No,
you hear about that.
What,
how do you say that stuff?
Cross home.
How do you say?
Keratome k r a t o,
m.
How do you say it?
Tony Kratom.
Kratom.
Maybe Kratom.
I don't know how to say it.
I've never said it,
but I've read about it a lot and uh,
it's uh,
a plant that helps people overcome
opioid addiction apparently.
And the FDA just moved into schedule one
or they're going to move it to schedule
one or the dea I should say.
I guess it's the Dea,
right?
But it's,
it's a plant
and apparently it helps a lot of people
that have a heroin addiction problems
and opiate addiction problems.
And even some people said it helps with
a marijuana,
not marijuana,
but alcohol withdrawals,
people,
alcoholics,
and they try to break free and get
sober.
This stuff can help with that too.
I don't know enough about it,
you know,
I'm going to,
I'm going to have someone on to talk
about it,
but it's just,
there's no need to make anything else
illegal like this,
this thing where they're doing what
they're doing is they're behaving like
an archaic society.
They're not behaving like America.
Two Thousand and 16,
they're behaving like the people who
enacted the very first sweeping
psychedelic laws of 1970.
They're behaving like they behave.
If you've got this plant,
this Kratom or however you say it,
and it doesn't have any history of
people like dropping dead from it,
it's not like some threat to the
communities.
It's not like this a terror that's
sweeping the streets and it's ruining
lives.
You're not hearing that.
All I'm hearing is it helps people with
heroin addiction.
We all know how many people are addicted
to heroin,
so the fact that they just want to step
in and immediately not just make this
like a schedule two or schedule three or
have some scientists come in and testify
about it and have some sort of public
hearings where they discuss the merits
of keeping this drug legal and should
this be regulated?
Should it be prescribed by doctors like
reasonable adults would do if they
actually gave a fuck about each other,
but instead they have these fucking
ridiculous amounts of power where they
could just step in and just make things
illegal.
They have a ridiculous amount of power
when it comes to legislating what we can
and can't do with our bodies because
it's not something anybody's voting on
this kratom stuff.
So for the dea to just step in and make
that schedule one,
it's blasphemy like what they're doing
is a,
it's a.
it's such an abuse of the function of
the office.
The idea of the office is you're
supposed to be protecting people,
protect people from math,
protect people from bad ship.
Don't.
Don't let people come home to find their
children that have overdosed because
someone gave them bath salts,
right?
That's,
that's what everybody wants from
something like the dea,
but they're so far reaching with their
efforts that they step into all these
areas where we know you're full of shit.
Now you step in these areas like
marijuana or you're going to save people
from pot.
Congratulations you fucking cock
blocker.
What are you gonna?
Do you're gonna say people from giggling
or eating yummy food or having a good
time with their friends.
What are you going?
What are you?
What are you stopping?
These are.
This is not anything that we should
ever.
Not not anything we should ever asked
for from our leaders in quotes,
and definitely not anything we should
ever tolerate for no reason whatsoever.
There's no reason whatsoever why they
would keep marijuana illegal.
There's no reason whatsoever other,
whether it would make this kratom stuff
scheduled ones.
There's no fucking reason.
It's money.
It's.
It is.
It's a sure sign that it's a corrupt
system and if that,
if that kratom stuff helps with alcohol
withdrawals,
then you got to know that these big
companies would.
Why wouldn't they pitched them some
money to be like,
hey,
lets you don't want me drinking.
Even if they didn't do it blatantly,
even if they didn't do a blatantly,
if they're entangled with each other,
you can best believe that if you were
entangled with some sort of an alcohol
company,
you're going to do your best to maximize
the profits of that alcohol company.
Right?
I mean it's just the way it is.
If you're entangled with some donor to
some political campaign or some some
foundation that you run and they give
millions of dollars,
like you guys have a little agreement
going on there.
You don't have to even say it.
You don't have to have it written down.
You don't have to be stupid about it,
but it's pretty obvious.
If someone gives you millions of bucks
there,
you know you guys are how your guys are
doing business.
Something's happening here,
you know you're to do nice things for
each other now and that's,
that's where a lot of this shit comes
from.
Like the fact that we,
the people,
the people that are supposed to be
represented by these clowns can sit back
and just be frustrated and not do
anything.
We could vote for it when it comes up in
our states,
but federally it's a giant issue.
Federally,
federally is the real problem because
there's a bunch of states now that made
it illegal including Washington dc.
It's a bunch of states that have made
pot legal there.
They're like,
look,
it's ridiculous.
Doesn't the science and Fit p?
And then they start taxing it and then
they make unbelievable amounts of money
and then they have massive research that
says in their economy like you're seeing
in Colorado and now you're seeing in
Seattle in Washington state as well.
What they're doing is they're.
They're being ironical like these.
These,
this is not like reasonable people
acting in a reasonable way that they're
locking people up for a long time.
Oh my God.
There was this fucking thing the other
day where they were comparing that kid
who raped the girl in.
What University was that?
Who's got like a ridiculously short
amount of time?
What's that?
You don't have a mic on Stanford.
Stanford.
Is that what it is?
That guy.
So they compared that guy to some poor
bastard that.
Oh my God,
I think he got 30 years for growing pot.
Did you see that picture?
Did you see it too?
I think it was even longer than 30
years,
man.
It might've been.
It might've been like 30 to life or
something,
but it's just the idea that you would
lock that guy away for that long for
something so fucking innocuous will loan
book below the law.
It's real simple.
We got a law and you don't want to break
it.
Okay.
You took your consequences.
We're adults here.
We're all adults.
These laws are stupid.
We're being handicapped by these ancient
systems,
these ancient systems of control.
They don't.
They're not valid anymore.
You can't just lock people up for pot.
It's stupid.
Here it is.
Lee.
Carol Brooker,
a 75 year old veteran,
served a life sentence in prison without
parole for being caught growing three
dozen marijuana plants behind my son's
house.
Wow.
Oh my God.
And it says,
hi.
I'm Brock Turner,
20 year old who raped a woman on campus.
I just got six months in prison.
I'm also promised that with good
behavior that would be cut down to three
months.
Jesus Christ.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's already out and there's like a
armed protestors outside of his house.
Oh my God.
I'm so rape before joint skies.
Yeah.
No,
that's just crazy.
If you're going to rape a girl,
don't do it on a pile of marijuana
plants.
That's what we learned here.
That'd be a good idea.
Plus three months.
Good.
Pardon?
From Obama.
I think
that guy.
Yes,
but Ken Obama,
like reverse the sentence and put that
kid back in jail.
But the rapist back in jail.
Did He.
Did he admit to doing it?
I think I didn't they.
It was one of those things.
I think we're like,
she got drunk,
she fell asleep and he banged her while
she was out cold.
Yeah,
I think so.
What is it behind a dumpster though?
Yeah,
that's right.
Oh,
that's the one,
right?
Yeah.
I passed out behind a dumpster.
God Damn.
That's like heard of that,
but I've never actually,
you know,
I didn't realize people actually could
pass up 100 dumpster.
Like I've never been that drunk to where
that's where I would lay down.
I fucked by a dumpster but never slept
there.
He fucked by a dumpster,
a dumpster grease on the ground.
Now.
Slippery boxes down.
But
Oh my God,
what a classy girl you must been.
I told you about this and the guy came
out and he caught us having sex and he's
like,
oh,
you got nervous.
He's like,
Oh,
you guys want some pizza?
Because he thought we were homeless.
Homeless Bank too.
Homeless People Bang on pizza boxes next
to dumpsters.
That's pretty much it.
There's this homeless guy that lives by
or lives on the bench outside my
starbucks and then he has gang green or
diabetes or something so bad that his
legs are just like purple and black and
I was behind him in starbucks walking in
and every time you took a step like this
open sore but just like squirt blood on
the floor of star.
It was the grossest thing in there in
the world.
What did he get to drink?
I don't want to waters.
He thought he was taking a bath or
something.
But yeah,
that's a problem.
If you're running a business and that
guy walks in,
what do you do?
They're super nice to him too because
he's there every day just sleeping on
the bench.
The homeless thing is weird,
right?
Because those are people.
They are people but goddamn they stink,
you know?
And it's like when they're around you,
they're,
they're reaching their hands out.
Like if you run into one of them cookie
homeless people that doesn't bathe ever.
And then you know,
they have like those dirty caked feet
and they're wandering around.
What I see is like a mentally ill
person,
you know,
what I see is like a failure of the
healthcare system or like how do you
just let this person wander around like
this.
Like this is like they're having
conversations with themselves and
rummaging through their fucking shopping
cart.
It's a very serious problem in La.
The other day I saw something gross
right in my neighborhood.
Like right at my intersection,
I saw a homeless lady sitting on a bus
bench and it looked like she was
wiggling her pants down a little bit.
She did and she's just sitting on the
bench and you know,
it has those greats.
It's not just like a solid bench.
It goes through and she paid just
through right through the greats.
Like it was nothing.
Just p flying out of her,
oh my God.
And I couldn't stop watching.
All of a sudden I'm just like,
you know,
it's amazing because you're,
you're looking at the amount of Pii
that's coming out of this human being.
This guy sad
because we just leave those people out
there and I think this guy's a vet.
Like that's what's even crazier that he
fought for us and now he can't get
medical attention for free.
You know,
it's also,
some of them you have to think probably
just left.
They didn't want to deal with the
healthcare system.
They didn't want to be medicated all the
time.
They didn't want to stay in a loony bin.
But then there was like Rayon during the
Reagan administration that they let them
loose on the streets like zombies.
They changed the,
uh,
whatever the standard of treatment,
like,
you know,
had to treat someone if they're x amount
of crazy like that,
you're on your own crazy flux and they
just pushed them out into the street and
there was just an influx of homeless
people.
You find them all over the east coast.
It was,
it was real weird.
It was a big problem.
I remember that.
I think San Francisco,
it was a big deal up there.
It's a real big deal in places like
Boston.
That's where homelessness is a big deal
because when they're out there they can
fucking free solid.
You can die out there.
I was uh,
I was with Jeff Ross when he taped his
special roast,
the police where we did ride alongs with
the Boston police department during the
winter and these cops,
they know all the homeless people,
every single one of them and they show
genuine concern and like,
you know,
that they have to go up to these guys
and be like,
Yo,
the shelter,
it's open,
you know,
get in there.
It's a whole thing.
Like,
it's,
that's actually during the winter time,
one of their main things,
and this is when all the,
you know,
obviously there's been a cop shootings
and this and that,
but their main concern for the most
part,
what we did on these ride alongs was
tell homeless people to get to the
shelter.
They're just going to freeze.
It's pretty much what Boston cops are
doing during the winter unless there's a
crazy call.
It's just a,
such a sad aspect of our society,
like the people that are just,
it's just for whatever reason,
whether it's a mental issue just doesn't
click.
There's just something that's not
clicking in there.
Right.
And then just wandering around through
the streets and there's no one with
them,
you know,
and they're just living in this strange
life.
I always wonder like what is reality to
those people?
I was just going to say,
I always wonder what they're thinking.
Like sometimes it seems like they're
having so much fun.
Do you remember that Robin Williams
movie?
Robin Williams played a crazy homeless
guy that lives in central park and used
to think he was a night or something
like that.
Oh yeah.
What the fuck was that movie?
It was like a mental illness movie was a
movie about a Fisher King.
The Fisher King.
Yeah.
Robin Williams was completely out of his
mind
and he played this really I,
if I,
if there is that,
I believe that's the plot of the movie.
I hope we're not fucking it up,
but that was the thing is that this guy
was seeing some things that just weren't
there.
I mean obviously when you see those
people talk to themselves or something
going on there.
Yeah.
I wonder what it's like,
what if it's like the simpsons ride at
universal,
like everything they see is like,
whoa,
hey,
I like to think that they're smarter
than us and they like talking to people
that they can see that are actually
there,
but we are.
We can't figure it out.
A former radio DJ suicidally despondent
because of terrible mistakes he made,
finds redemption in helping a deranged
homeless man who was an unwitting victim
of that mistake.
Huh?
I don't remember much about this movie.
Suicidally.
Despondent.
Crazy,
right?
Yeah.
Have you ever written that a simpsons
ride at universal now?
Drop everything I have with the shooting
one,
right?
You like shoot?
No,
no,
no.
The simpsons ride like you sit in like a
car,
but it's sort of like everything is
happening.
The car moves around a little bit left
and right,
but everything that's happening is
happening on the screen in front of you
like the screen,
this gigantic
high def screen where you're in a first
person perspective and you know it's
taking on this wild,
crazy fucking amazingly illustrated
cartoon rot.
It's fucking fun,
Dude.
It's really fun.
Scott.
Smells to remember the baby powder smell
and it smells like when Maggie's on the
screen.
It's one of the best rides ever.
It's so good.
I was really surprised at the
transformers ride too.
Is that good kids?
Great.
And work for a minute.
I was on that one.
I didn't like it.
Really thought it was like,
whoa.
I will extend with the simpsons first.
Yeah.
Not to move.
Mentioned that Harry Potter thing yet at
the Harry Potter rides.
Amazing.
So weird.
Because I live next to universal and
you're just driving and now there's a
castle that you just drive.
I'm like,
why is Eric?
Oh yeah,
Harry Potter.
It's cool.
It's a long ass ride to the Harry Potter
ride is really long.
I don't know how long it takes,
but you're like,
Whoa,
this is ride keeps going.
How do you go to university?
You go when it's closed or something.
Just go.
Whatever.
It was.
Just go.
That place is crazy for anybody.
I can't imagine what it's like for you
on.
We'll just go where this guy definitely
not rocking your fanny pack at
university.
My fanny pack there.
Heck yeah,
that's the best place to wear it.
How dare you say I want.
They just want my family back at
Disneyland.
Get swamped.
Just say hi to people.
Say Hi and keep moving.
Yeah.
Did you talk about this George Carlin's
cd that are uh,
that he recorded the day before nine
slash 11?
No.
Have you heard about this?
He recorded a special the day before
nine slash 11.
It was actually called.
I kinda like it when a lot of people
die.
Oh No.
And then the following day,
nine slash 11 happened.
So they had to shelve it and I guess
even in it he talks about Osama bin
Ladin Holy Shit,
Shit like that.
And so there were about to release it or
they just released it.
They've held onto it this long is
because of nine slash 11.
It's really creepy.
A bunch of weird nine slash 11,
things like that.
I looked up,
I found a couple yesterday actually it
was like a,
there's a band that was called.
We are the World Trade Center.
I am the World Trade Center.
It was like a synth pop band in April of
2001.
They released a song again,
the name of the band.
We are the World Trade Center and track
11 on that album that came out in April.
Track 11 was called September.
So like if you look at their albums near
the World Trade Center,
11 dot September,
that's crazy.
So insane.
And then there's
another thing.
Then there's another thing I can't
remember which cartoon and it's either
like Futurama,
I think it is,
but it's the craziest thing I saw in a
long time in one of these weird
cartoons.
There was a moment where it pans over
from them and there's a movie poster on
the wall and it.
And this was before nine slash 11,
like right before nine slash 11.
And it looks like a World Trade Center
smoking like blatantly.
Exactly like a world trade center fire.
There you go.
And um,
it says coming soon on the thing,
like a movie poster just says coming
soon.
And they're blatantly a world trade
center smoking.
It's the craziest thing I've seen in a
long time.
I think it's either.
Futurama,
I think though,
as much content as people put out and
the World Trade Center was always these
iconic references.
I mean it was in a Biggie Song,
you know,
blow up like the world trade.
Yeah.
You know,
cover.
Yeah.
And those people did try to blow it up
in,
was it like 96 or something like that?
They,
they blew up that car bomb inside the
basement.
So it makes sense that somebody would
have caught it.
But that 11 and September,
that's bananas.
Yeah.
That's some fucking premonition shit
it happened.
You think they planned that?
Like that,
like knowing that nine slash 11 not but
like knowing that if we do it on nine
slash 11,
it's nine slash 11.
It's like emergency numbers,
marketing one on one.
It was easier,
you know,
they knew it was going to be a bigger
deal because it's 9:11,
nine slash 11,
you know the maybe
yeah,
maybe it would have happened in nine
slash 12 and been just as fucked up and
people find reasons to attach numbers in
meanings to things,
but it's totally possible that they know
are.
I mean,
obviously they know nine slash 11 is for
emergency,
that they did it on nine slash 11
because of that,
but would have made any difference.
It was nine,
nine or 9:10.
It was.
It was a devastating attack and tragedy.
The other stuff is just like,
really?
If they did it on July 11th,
seven slash 11 would have gone out of
business everywhere.
Seven.
Sorry.
Were you going with that?
If there's going to be more to this,
that's it.
But like thinking about that,
about people for seven,
11 July fourth will be a big smack in
our face and march would be really good
if it was March 11th at 3:11.
Oh,
that,
that band?
Yeah.
They make good weed pens.
Yeah,
they do.
Just one of the first people to smoke
the prototype last year on the 3:11
crews with peanut.
The Bass player.
How strong is that,
Ben?
They make their own weed pens.
It's a very strong move.
They're the coolest man.
They have,
like they've always been ahead of the
game.
Live show.
It's because they're all generic.
Uh,
like Chinese,
you know,
models.
So anyone can make their own weed pen by
just putting a logo on it.
You can buy them in bulk.
Yeah,
I've seen all the same.
We'd pins you can go to.
There's this website you can buy like
300 of them and they'll even like put a
logo on it for you.
So it looks like your we'd pin.
They were red.
They were really hands on with this one
though.
This they like tried out a ton of.
I know because he told us all about it
but that would just be like the oil.
So they tried out a ton of canisters to.
I just know that it took them like they
should,
like they went through a long process.
So probably both.
It's good stuff comes up.
A highly approved.
You try the orange one.
I don't know what one I tried.
That's what I remember is it tasted like
an actual orange and got me correct.
Yeah.
No that's good stuff.
Atheist's nightmare acs night man.
It's this.
Well it
is intelligent design though.
Somebody made it there.
Um,
those bands also.
Like what kind of band is three?
One,
one,
three,
11 is really their own type of thing
because it's like ray gay mixed with
heavy rock,
like they go back and forth.
Sometimes it's,
sometimes you'll just forget that
they're about to like drop.
Like they have killer guitarist and high
energy.
They have two lead singers,
one guy with a really smooth voice and
the other guys sorta like a rapper do
all this while they're high.
Alright.
Oh,
I'd imagine so.
But also like,
I feel like a couple of days,
I feel like a lot of those guys have
families now and stuff and uh,
they might calm down a little bit,
but I'm sure they,
they have to get stoned.
I used to like them.
I haven't heard anything from them in a
long time.
Well they made a greatest hits album way
back in like 98 or something like that.
You know,
that they are,
they are notorious for being one of the
best live bands to see if there's a
whole cruise ship with them.
Right?
Yeah.
It was the coolest thing I've ever done.
Thought it was about,
uh,
it was actually five days.
I did two shows and I was like shaky
about it because this was back when like
that,
like toilets exploded on that one cruise
or whatever.
Everybody died.
Well,
everybody is freaking out.
It's like
one where the guy was trying to wave.
His girlfriend came around with the boat
and then he,
uh,
hit the ground and killed like a ton of
people.
Bunch of people.
I'm talking about carnival one that
like,
got all poopy everywhere.
Oh,
that one too.
Yeah,
I remember that.
That happened right around then and I'm
like,
man,
I cruise ship we're going to see.
But I knew three slash 11 was an awesome
life band like I did out of.
I've seen them actually quite a few
times.
Like in high school and stuff,
dude,
there's a railing
below that railing is the ocean and
you're going 50 miles an hour.
Good luck.
It's awesome.
Fuck you.
I had so much fun because they're
performing on the main deck.
Fun cruises.
I agree.
Fuck cruises.
So tell me what it was like.
It was the greatest thing ever.
I came back from that five day cruise
and got everything in my life done like
crazy because it's so.
It's literally perfect.
Going to Jamaica on the most boring part
of the whole trip was the half a day we
spent in Jamaica before getting back on
and going,
I stepped on some needle.
These sponge in the ocean like,
this sucks.
Get back on this luxury cruise ship.
A bunch of shows going on.
There's a casino you can get away to
your room if you want to disappear.
It's really a thousand times better than
I thought it was going to be.
If you didn't like Jamaica.
Now it's now
good.
God.
No.
Well I'll go ahead and try the chicken.
It was like just bad.
Everybody's cooking and it's just dirty.
There's bees everywhere in nature like
sucks,
but cruise ships are great because it's
like a fake name.
Going 50 miles an hour with Caribbean
era around you is perfect.
I mean it's the perfect life.
Oh,
you're going to live on boat when you're
an old crazy
man.
You're.
Are you going to be like one of them?
Howard Hughes type dudes?
Just out on a boat,
just John Hubbard style with your own
captain's outfit,
who give yourself metals every year.
Highs for a new job today I'm want to
get myself a metal pin.
A metal onto your.
You would have like a camel colored
coat.
Maybe a light camel.
Something sophisticated.
Yeah,
probably.
Well my older brother just got like way
in way into it.
Bought a boat and everything and he's
been sailing for like a decade,
but he's like way into it now.
Yeah.
He's got a cool apartment right on
Venice beach and a boat and the dock.
So he just goes blah,
blah,
blah.
Well,
I'm going to go into the ocean.
It makes sense.
I mean it's like a giant uncharted area
or a an a on.
There's no roads.
There's no like you can go wherever you
want.
Like that's the cool thing about like
being in the ocean.
If you have a boat,
there's no road.
There's no one.
You have to go here.
You have to take a right there and you
take the 1:10 to the 18th.
No,
no.
Let's just go wherever you want to go.
What do you want to go?
You want to go to Catalina?
Go to Catalina.
It's crazy.
Life under there.
You throw a fishing pole out to catch
something.
You throw it on the grill right there.
You just scan it.
Pam.
Don't even have to get up or down.
You know?
They're finding out that a lot of those
tropical fish are making their ways into
the waters around southern California
because of the global warming,
so they're having like yellowfin tuna or
all over southern California.
Water's.
We used to have to go to like Hawaii to
catch those things so we can catch them
right here now.
That's awesome.
Getting your boats on.
Then the cruise ship thing.
I'm telling you.
I mean it's a.
it's a whole thing,
but what if someone's really annoying?
They just fall.
You were on that cruise ship.
That doesn't happen.
Stuck on them.
It doesn't happen now.
You can lose them.
You could lose him.
Did you have a huge.
You have to understand how huge this is.
Like a mall.
It's like a small city.
Yes.
It's like a giant mall or a small city.
How long does it take to walk around?
Was also like six or seven floors.
You know what I mean?
So boom,
boom,
boom.
That's what it's all like a hotel.
Almost like a Vegas hotel.
It's floating.
That's what it's like.
It's like a vegas style.
Huge hotel.
Like how the mgms connected to the New
York,
New York or whatever.
It's like super duper huge and the main
deck,
I mean they're doing shows at nighttime
and it is unbelievable going to a normal
concert where you're just not moving
after that.
Sort of like,
I'm missing something here.
They must have cruises that go
successfully every day to their
destination.
Smooth.
Everyone has a great experience.
There is no issues whatsoever.
It's like airplanes.
All it takes is one poopy mistakes.
There's one dude who wants a wave at his
girlfriend and beaches the boat and
drowned a bunch of people or one husband
who throws his wife over the side to
hear about that guy.
There was a guy who through his wife
over the side like newlyweds.
There's some fucking creepy people out
there,
man.
There's a cruise ship website like
cruise ship reports.org
or something like that and it tells you
every time there's a problem with a
cruise ship and it's shocking how many
there are.
There's like problems all the time and
like,
and it shows how many people died and
stuff and why and how and how often do
people die from cruise.
Crazy shit happens on cruise.
Like you sold the elevator,
right?
The guy that got stuck in the elevator
and it started dripping down blood of
his body because he got crushed on the,
on the cruise ship in a couple months
ago,
dripping down black.
This guy working on an elevator and the
elevator crushed them.
And so he was working on the elevator
and went up to the top and then.
So there's video of just blood gushing
down the elevator door and people are
like,
what the heck is that?
And it's just blood like it looks like a
horror movie.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
But there's a real.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
It's on the video.
You got to see that.
They don't need to see that.
It sets a weird way to go though.
Get squashed in an elevator.
This is why I don't work on elevators.
People ask me all the time,
Tony,
we have a problem with the elevator.
Can you get on top of it and fix it?
Innovator before?
No.
Yeah,
when I was a little kid.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
It was like seven years old,
but have only 20 minutes,
you know,
like probably blew a fuse or something
like that.
But um,
I was in New York recently at one of the
theaters.
I think it was the beacon and they have
this dude who runs the elevator back
there.
Yeah,
I was with you.
That's right.
You remember that the guy had like the
handle and the exchanging.
It's like old school.
The old school elevator where you have
to have an operator is like you.
There's no buttons to press.
This guy had to get you up and down.
So it was.
Would it be saved from the 19 twenties
or something like that?
Yeah,
it might.
Yeah.
What's that might have been before that
net total.
Nineteen,
29.
Oh,
that's it.
That's right.
I took a video of the dude.
Wasn't that brother Jose?
Jose.
This is a old elevator.
We're in here.
How long has this kind of elevator been
here for 20 night.
I said.
Yeah,
it was the old ones on instagram.
You can only get 15 seconds or 30
seconds or something like that.
Yeah,
but that dude was operating that thing
like you had.
It was a little lever to pull up and
pull down bad ass hold elevator,
but I'm sure they fix it all the time.
Yeah.
This thing up to that,
it's always.
You can.
There's always that thing on the inside.
That was in Italy.
I got an elevator from the 1800,
the hotel at a 18.
Hundreds of elevator.
Yeah.
It's super weird.
There's old ones.
You guys shut the door and shut the door
and get to get inside.
It'll still work,
but yeah,
we'll just leave the door open.
Yeah,
you could just door open and grab the
floor as you're passing and rip your
fucking arms off.
He could do that
if you looked at like how many people
died from elevators versus how many
people have died from coconuts.
You'd be shocked.
No one's scared of coconuts,
but coconuts.
Fuck up about 150 people here should
know that.
Now,
do you know when people die deer every
year?
A lot.
200 in the United States.
Wow.
200 deaths.
They die from deer every year.
Every year you're driving down the road
listening to led Zeppelin,
and you hit this stupid fucking county
forest horse and it goes flying through
your windshield and kicks your brains
out.
Two hundred people a year.
How many people do you think die on
average in elevators per year?
I know pretty in the US.
Six prince's.
One of them.
Twenty six did die in an elevator.
Yeah,
for real.
Yeah.
Twenty 6 million elevators every year in
the United States.
Jesus.
How many die from coconuts?
I'm saying coconuts.
Over 100 a year.
I think so worldwide.
I would say worldwide.
More than 100 people a year die from
coconuts.
Coconuts.
Coconuts falling on their head.
Not Allergy.
Skin jacked.
Fiftieth.
Yeah.
Bitch.
That's worldwide,
worldwide.
Good.
Imagine if it was all in Jakarta,
in Jakarta,
coconuts and people
walking home from school with your
buddies to have them die.
I just a chest an embarrassing way to
die,
right?
Oh No.
That,
that Husky sound.
Those things clobbering you on the head
song.
The last thing you hear is your friends
laughing at you because that's probably
how they figured out.
The coconuts were edible.
It killed someone's friend.
Someone freaked out and hit it with a
rock and went,
oh,
we're good.
This is some shit in here.
I killed my friend back then you are
dead.
They didn't know that a coconut wasn't
alive.
If something came out of the sky and
killed your friend and you know you were
so stupid that you didn't even have
clothes yet.
That's probably the first people that
figured out they could eat coconuts.
It'd be like the first balls,
right?
Fruits.
Mike probably sort of just hearing now.
They realized they could play soccer and
stuff for sure.
Definitely.
Wow.
Dude.
I saw a demonstration of the day.
We've showed demonstrations that lie
next stuff before,
but this was the most ridiculous one lie
next is this plastic stuff that they can
spray on things and they sprayed on like
the undercarriages of some trucks and
like,
like four wheelers that go out into the
country.
You know those guys.
Those dudes do those four.
We'll crawl fucking things and smashed
up against rocks.
They'll lie next to their whole truck.
They'll.
That'll be the paint for the outside of
it.
Well,
they took a watermelon.
They sprayed a watermelon with lynette
and dropped it off of like,
I think it was like from 450 feet up.
This is the brick one.
This is when we've already seen.
But this one's kind of fascinating to
like check this out.
Like just show how they did it before.
So they,
they drop this brick off the top of the
building now and without the Linacs oh,
that's a,
that's when they shot the walls,
the watermelon video.
But there's a bunch of shit before it.
Oh,
is it the watermelon woman?
Oh yeah.
It is.
There.
Trying to find it there.
It's right there,
these guys.
So anyway,
there's one of them where they're on a
tower.
The tower one is a watermelon one dude.
I think it's a different one.
Yeah,
it's not the same video.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Take all of these are in there.
This is a different one because this one
it's red,
but it's the same goddamn thing.
So I guess they just couldn't hit it
with a hammer here.
They sprayed this shit on a watermelon,
but the watermelon just.
He's like hitting it with a hammer.
It's just bouncing,
but that's not as impressive.
Cv,
you could find the one where they
dropped the watermelon off the tower
lie.
Next.
Watermelon,
450 feet drop.
I mean they threw this watermelon off
the tower without the line x and it hits
the street and literally vaporizes just.
They hit it.
The throw the [inaudible].
It hits the ground.
It bounces 10 feet in the air that the
inside of it was just watermelon juice.
It just became watermelon juice.
But this stuff is so tough.
It's just some weird freaky plastic.
That'd be fun to like Prank Gallagher
before he goes onstage.
Sprays water break is back,
open its arms would literally fly off
his body.
So you can you buy this consumer?
Yeah.
It's just.
I know my friend Remy,
his dad actually owns a shop up in Reno
where they spray trucks with this stuff.
Wow.
Yeah.
Like people that want like a really
heavy duty application of their trucks
are going to drive in the woods and
branches are going to smack up against
it all the time.
They just spray their whole truck with
this shit.
That's cool.
Yeah.
There's a company called m
d I think it's called Dev Rolo d e V e r
o l o.
and they make these ridiculous souped up
Toyota Tundras that are bulletproof and
they spray line x all over them.
So like they,
they make them like regular and they
make them bulletproof that like they
make them for like,
you know,
some royal family or some shit that
comes here from somewhere else and they
have this.
What is this?
This is the video of the.
Yeah,
lie next.
Didn't make some other guys just put
this video out a couple like this past
month.
Linacs didn't make the video,
but they did use line x,
so let's watch it.
Like here you go.
So he throws this watermelon
off.
This ridiculous fucking power.
Look at this.
It hits the ground.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Wow.
Now can you cut into it like is it
possible to get to that watermelon now
or is it like,
yeah,
you can cut it into,
but look at this.
Look how hits the ground.
It's like a ball.
I mean it seems like a medicine ball,
like someone threw a medicine ball.
What about bullet versus that?
What happened?
No bullet would go through it.
It's just it has a unique ability to
disperse,
shock and rebound and not break open.
It's really cool.
See if you find those trucks,
Dev Rolo,
it's called.
I think it's like some Russian company
or something like that.
They make these souped up cars that are
covered in this shit about a lot of
companies do that.
I guess cover business line shit to
protect it from accidents then yes,
it would definitely protect you more
from accidents and not having it for
sure.
It would definitely make it harder for
an impact to get,
you know,
like if your.
If your car has a certain thickness of
steel on the door and you had double
that thickness,
I would just assume there'll be safer.
Right.
Doesn't that make sense?
Well,
it makes you wonder like if it caves in
then that also absorbs a lot of the
energy.
But if you have bounced off it seems
like there'd be more snapping.
Snapping.
I'll take the snapping to the
penetrating.
That's how you.
Your body gets crushed by a truck
hitting you on the side.
I don't know.
Maybe a combination of the two.
Yeah,
I don't.
I think maybe I'm
just make sense that if it was a
thicker,
stronger material,
like if you were driving around in a
tissue paper car,
you'd feel real nervous.
Right.
It just seems to reason that if you
would get thicker and thicker gauge of
metal,
so if you took like a regular gauge
metal that they have on like a Chevy
Silverado or something like that and you
spray this line,
x shit over it,
this has got to make it stronger.
There's just no way it doesn't.
If that's what it does with a watermelon
off a 450 foot tower,
what was you remember Saturn's where you
can scratch them.
You could kick them and they never.
They were made out of plastic.
Is that plastic?
Wouldn't that be like a safety hazard
then if it was plastic?
No,
no,
because as long as it's
strong,
like plastics can be really fucking
strong.
Like there's certain types of plastics,
like certain types of composite fibers
that elect technically plastics that are
ridiculously strong.
Like they use resins and they have these
types of plastics that they can,
you know,
they can make plastic where you can make
a plastic knife.
We could kill somebody with it.
I mean plastic can be really hard.
That's why it's such a good feature.
That car,
I loved my Saturn and when I sold it it
was like 12 years old and it looked like
the day I bought it or like brand new
because it didn't scratch her.
Did they make those anymore?
Now they went out of business,
but that technology that you think they
would use it in other cars are and it's
probably not gonna last.
I think cars want to break and go get
more parts.
Like gms are like,
they like that thick at these trials.
This is a pocket
immobile.
Wow.
That looks great.
Nothing insane.
One Mile per gallon.
Yeah.
Click on one of the pictures of them.
Things like the interceptor,
the challenger,
the expedition.
Yeah.
So all that stuff is linacs there.
The entire outside of the truck,
the bumpers.
Everything is covered in that line.
X Shit does it God damn tank.
That thing.
You got a little Dick.
That's your ride.
You're like,
okay,
I want to distract you.
Like bullet bullet tests on it or
anything,
you know?
Will they do have bulletproof versions
of the car?
I don't know if that stuff is
bulletproof.
I would doubt that it is,
but I would say it's definitely better
than not having it on,
but look at that thing.
So manly.
Ooh,
I got you to Ben and Kevin prayers.
Auto drive car the other day.
Oh,
the Tesla.
It took you froze.
Whoa.
Cool man.
So weird.
And that.
Yeah,
when he did it,
it's hard to trust that like it's,
it's weird him just like letting go.
And he said when he first bought it he
was really scared and nervous,
but now he's like,
you know,
laptop out like doing shit you shouldn't
be doing.
And,
and I watched it like detect the,
you know,
the side car and stuff like that.
And it stopped.
It slowed down
because you know,
the guy that designed the self driving
car was Asian and you're like,
you know,
how do you know his age limit Asian,
Asian computer people.
This is a bad attempt at some racist
humor and I'm not going to get.
I can guarantee you the person that find
it engineered the self driving cars and
Asian.
If you're wrong,
you have to suck.
Brian Cochran,
show him.
I'll take a couple of strokes in your
mouth.
No,
I'll take the donkey cousin.
Just real quick little but the uh,
the figure wrong that the IPAD or
whatever,
the display and stuff.
Crazy screen sexy,
but does it well,
I would think that like,
that would use up a lot of juice.
Like why would you have such a giant
screen?
It seems like if you have a true.
Yeah.
But you know,
I didn't know.
I didn't know about the fast charging
because we always talked about this in
the past about how like you can't drive
to vegas though,
where they also have a stop in Vegas
that you plug it in for five minutes and
you get like two more hours.
Here's his effect though.
What was the last time you drove to
Vegas?
Uh,
drove up for the fight.
That's the five months ago.
I always drive.
It's,
it's cheap.
Well,
it's cheap,
but don't you get annoyed being in the
car for four hours now.
I'm used to four hours of fun.
Me and pete smoke jolene wholly on like,
let's say that you were driving back
though when you were in that Vegas
traffic on the way back.
It was terrible.
It's true.
You just owned you.
Yeah,
but you're stuck though.
It's two lanes for 400 miles to make it
to the stop.
You'd be three hours away from it.
He's right.
Fuck,
you know.
I mean there's not just one.
There's not just one thing.
There's a lot,
but he's got a really good point.
If you're stuck in that crazy vegas
traffic coming home,
you know how ridiculous I traffic is
traffic that makes you wake up at 4:00
in the morning just to avoid it.
Yeah,
I did it once.
I did it once and I barely made it
because I left at 7:30.
I was like,
I'll just get up before everybody else.
Oh No,
no.
People are already up and driving at
7:30.
It messed me up last week and coming
back from Mcgregor Diaz because they're
like,
you gotta gotta gotTa beat the traffic.
I'm like,
whatever.
If we get there,
I ended up missing the summer slam
party.
I Miss Summer Slam last week,
which was huge.
Poor baby.
How long did it take you to drive home?
It was like six,
seven hours,
something like that.
See,
that is fucking ridiculous.
Never been caught in that.
So ridiculous.
But if you had a gasoline,
like a buddy of mine has a 50 gallon
tank in his truck.
Fifty gallons so he could just drive it,
fills that bitch up
and just.
I mean it gets shitty gas mileage.
There's a catch 22 because you're
packing around all that weight,
but if he's driving from vegas he
doesn't have to pull over.
It's like the opposite of a tesla.
Yeah.
I tried like my car's dead right now and
I tried to jump start my car with my
girlfriend's car,
which is a,
a Prius Prius and he can't do that.
It was the second little 12 volt battery
inside those cars.
Like it's not a regular it.
You can't do it.
It says in the book do not do.
You could just destroy this car.
Oh,
that would be crazy if you blew that car
up.
I know those cars blow up,
man.
How'd your car died?
My car's got dead.
So many things wrong with her.
Did you ever see
that?
A member,
when those fiscal Karmas blew up,
the fisker Karma was that dope looking
space age electric car that actually had
a solar panel on the roof and that solar
panel on the roof charged up your radio
so your radio wasn't draining the
battery as you were driving around and
they were cool looking cars like
definitely the best looking out of all
the electric cars and they left a bunch
of them on a dock in Brooklyn,
I think it was,
or a no,
North Carolina or something like that.
Anywhere.
Somewhere by the water and the water
came in the sea level.
Rose flooded the parking lot and all the
cars went underwater and started
exploding.
Wow.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
A.
I don't know.
We tried to find it last time,
right?
We couldn't find it.
Look,
look at them all.
They all just blew up.
Wow.
Pinto is.
Is that what it was in the eighties that
were blowing up?
Is that the right cars?
Because it said Tesla under there.
Okay.
Superstorm sandy.
Yeah.
16 fisker Karma,
you know,
and everybody was like,
yeah,
we're good.
And that company just went under.
It's like the space x rockets that keep
blowing up on the thing.
They're like,
hey,
we're going.
It's pretty soon we'll fly you out to
Mars.
But meanwhile they can't even get out of
Florida.
I wouldn't fly on one of those fucking
things for a hundred years for the.
Got It,
right.
Yeah.
It's a noxious.
She'd pull up a real fisker
Karma so you can see what one actually
looks like.
It was a beautiful car.
Justin Bieber had one.
It was totally chrome.
Oh,
that's it?
Yeah.
That car chrome,
that bitch.
I couldn't.
That one.
Oh,
are they back?
So the back river road.
Oh,
they have a new car.
The revero.
Ooh.
Why Karma?
It's always been Karma.
Okay.
I saw bieber driving that car once and
it is.
That should be illegal because you ever
see that episode of chips where the.
There was a truck driving a bunch of
mirrors in the sun,
hit the mirrors and all these people
were like flying off the freeway.
Same thing with that.
It was just like this giant glared
coming down the stream.
You go back,
do go back to the actual car.
I want to say it.
Scroll down.
What you were looking at right here.
What Brian was talking right there in
the middle?
Yeah.
Picture of their car wrap.
That's a wrap.
A wrap on it.
Oh God.
It's so pretty.
Is that a Karma
data is so pretty.
Karma revero because if they just
brought it back,
that is a beautiful car,
man.
That is a goddamn be.
That is without a doubt.
The best.
Looking out of all those electric cars
like by far is is this gas tank option
on it?
That's what I think so.
I don't think so.
I think this is all electric.
God Damn.
That thing is sweet.
That is sweet.
That's,
that's the.
That's so much better looking than all
the other ones because that looks like a
Maserati or something,
doesn't it?
I kind of like the BMW.
That's like that though.
That looks like a Maserati fucked at
Jaguar.
That's electrical at the beer that we go
on a vacation and come on Friday came in
a Jaguar and made that thing.
What's the BMW electric sports car that
kind of looks like that?
That's it.
I don't like that one.
Well,
it's.
It's kind of cool looking on the
outside,
but the issue is it has a really skinny
tires and it does piss poor performance.
It's not a fast car.
It's a super expensive car and it's just
super space age car,
but he looked at.
It's like zero to 60 in comparison to
like other cars at bmw makes like the m
four and look at.
It's like track time or trackability
sales.
Skinny.
His tires are.
See the back tires.
Those are really skinny,
like that's not.
Well,
no,
that's just what it comes with.
This is not like a performance car.
It's a beautiful sleek piece of amazing
automotive engineering.
It's design is incredible,
but that's not what I like.
A car that looks like that and actually
goes fast.
That's not.
I mean it probably goes fast in
comparison to a lot of shit,
but if you compare the numbers I bet to
like between that and like a porsche
nine slash 11 or something like that
would probably not even close.
Kevin did.
It's a tesla like zero to 70 while I was
in the car and I've been in like your
cars before in the past,
but it was like three seconds and there
was no engine sounds so it kind of
freaked you out.
It was like being on a roller coaster.
I.
It took my breath away.
It was like those cars are ridiculously
fast.
It's crazy.
And they're four wheel drive too,
right?
Yep.
It's four wheel drive and it has this
ridiculous engine where there's no
transmission.
Like in terms of like gears,
it's like a direct drive,
so it just just goes like instant on the
solar roof will create enough energy to
power the car.
No other vehicle sold in us has ever
offered this capability.
Our owners consider our solar roof and
important element in our brand identity.
And we listened today.
It's about to come out.
Oh,
in two days it comes out.
This whole episode has been a long
commercial.
No,
that is dope though.
That the fucking car.
I mean,
especially in La,
in La,
that means you can drive that thing
around all the time because it's always
sunny.
So if that thing actually can power the
car,
that's amazing.
It does not seem right to soon as that
hits a rock,
it's going to explode.
How much is it?
How much is this car?
I would assume we'll find out in two
days.
Um,
I would bet it's over 100 grand.
I think those are super expensive cars.
See if you could find out how much the
Karma was.
Is that just the power
of the car for like,
like the electronics and display but not
driving?
No.
Saying the first one and be able to
power the car.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's insane.
That is insane.
If they,
if they really did figure that out,
it's over.
If you could figure out a way to make a
car run,
especially here where it's sunny every
day just on solar power and you can
listen to radio.
You don't have to.
There's no restrictions and if you're
stuck in traffic,
it's not only is it not like draining
your battery is probably better because
it's just not using as much energy,
but it's just being blasted by the sun
and recharging.
Nighttime you're fucked.
Yeah,
but it feel like you would store enough
like a tesla does.
You know?
If it kept it at 100 percent,
I'd be just like a cell phone.
Be Amazing,
man.
If they could figure out how to do that,
that would be amazing.
I mean that would,
at least around here in Arizona and
places like Colorado,
places where it's sunny,
they would put other cars out of
business.
It doesn't seem possible though because
that sets a small solar panel I didn't
think.
Was that powerful enough to actually
power a car?
Think solar panels are getting more
efficient.
They must be.
Well,
I know that Elon Musk has this new solar
bank thing that they're doing for your
house where it's.
They'll put solar in your house and the
batteries themselves are so much smaller
than they've ever been before.
They're cool looking and they like stick
to your wall.
He'll like you have have the mounted on
the wall and it's just,
it's not like a whole room like you used
to need like a whole room filled with
batteries to run a house on solar power,
so not really that way anymore and as
these things are just going to get,
if just the idea that you could power a
house on solar power today is crazy but
true.
So if you can power a house,
it's just a matter of time before that
stuff gets better and better and better
to the point where.
I mean you could probably wind up doing
it in Seattle with what minimal sun
comes through.
The clouds that's going to happen.
They're going to keep making these
things better just like they've done
with everything else,
whether it's televisions or cell phones
or cars themselves.
Cars today,
dude,
this is the golden era for automobiles.
Like there's people look back and say,
oh,
they didn't.
Nobody designs cars like they didn't
sixties to look at to look at your
right.
Yeah,
those sixties cars were amazing to look
at,
but try steering one of those pieces of
shit.
Try hitting the brakes if fucking
stroller rolls out in front of your car
though.
Those things were terrible.
They were terrible handling.
They're terrible on every corner.
The car went bent sideways and then he
had to like hang on onto it while it
righted itself.
Like the whole car was made out of like
a flexible piece of aluminum tray,
like w,
w,
but they were shit.
Those cars were pieces of shit.
The design was terrible.
Like they literally would.
The air would hit them when they would
drive.
They were not only were they not
aerodynamic,
they will like scoops.
There were like a sale.
It was like driving with a sale.
Like the front actually caught the air
and it slowed the car down.
I don't know much about old cars.
I didn't have a dad growing up.
Yeah.
Portrait you being.
Well I didn't learn from my dad either.
My Dad really doesn't give a shit about
cars,
my stepdad.
But if you ever seen like an old like
show a 1970 dodge charger.
Here's a perfect example.
This shit is so an aerodynamic but
undeniably dope.
One of my favorite movies,
death proof.
I'm pretty sure that's around the type
of car.
It's a dodge challenger.
That's a challenger or charger.
I'm not a challenge,
but if your car and death proof.
Have you seen that movie?
I think that's.
That's.
That's a 70.
That's interesting.
I thought that was a 69.
Maybe they did something different to
the bumper cars.
A 70 it let go right above it.
Go right above it.
The one,
the black one.
Sorry.
That's.
That's one too,
but that black one.
That's a 70 car.
The bumper goes around the top all the
way around like a fish with its mouth
open.
I think that other one is a 69.
The far left one,
but that far left one.
It's fucking beautiful.
Look at that thing.
God,
I think that's a 69 now.
Unless maybe they changed the bumper.
Look how fucking sick that is.
Have you seen death proof?
I don't know.
Is that the Quentin Tarantino thing?
Yeah.
No,
you would love it.
Look what they just did.
They just reversed the picture.
Right hand,
left hand drive.
They just flip this picture around.
God,
that thing so pretty.
So that that car was in that movie that
I'm not exactly sure of,
but that's the car right there.
So
yeah,
that's a charger for sure.
There was one that they had in fast and
furious that was all bare metal and it
costs more than a million dollars to
make
is ridiculous.
It's silver now.
There's a silver one.
Silver Dodge charger.
Just Google Silver Jewelry,
silver dodge charger.
Fast and the furious.
Do you miss sick fish your own?
Have you?
Is it still alive?
No.
Fast.
And the furious Jamie A.
Yeah.
That Reggie Bush character has it.
Um,
that's it right there.
Look at that thing.
Wow.
There is no pain on that thing.
There's this clear coat over the bare
metal and it like,
it took forever to make the car.
Took years to make it like literally a
rolling work of art.
Hm.
It's crazy looking car.
No,
that's sick.
Fish was a piece of shit and it looked
great,
but it was,
it was just not sorted outright,
is not built correctly.
And that Reggie Bush guy had to do a
bunch of things to it after I did a
bunch of things to it.
I keep calling that Reggie Bush guy.
You're hearing this Reggie.
I'm just high.
Don't listen to me.
Do they?
No disrespect.
Did they make electric motorcycles?
Yes.
That is a dope car though.
I miss.
I miss it.
It wasn't a fun car to drive though.
Tell you that.
Is that you?
Yeah,
I'm just going to say it looks like that
was a I am,
but I had that car made in like a,
a for a TV show in like 2005 or
something like that.
It was a.
It was really pretty.
But the insides and the way it drove,
it was just,
it was designed to look really pretty.
It wasn't designed to drive well the
sound of it.
When you would pull into the comedy
store though,
it was so awesome.
It was ridiculous.
Giant engine five,
28.
Hemi just roared.
It was 600 and something horsepower.
Such a stupid car.
Just sounds like Joey Diaz murdering it
sounds like war.
It sounded like some death machine,
you know,
he just wasn't safe.
Like I had to get a bunch of things done
to it.
The suspension detached from the frame
in my driveway.
After I'd been on the highway going 70
miles an hour,
just 10 minutes before I pulled in,
pulled into my driveway and my car went
sideways and I was like,
what the fuck?
And I get out and the wheel is like half
hanging off and dug into the quarter.
The fender.
I was like,
what the fuck?
I was just on the highway.
Like if that broke loose on the highway,
I could've easily been dead.
He's like,
when you're going 70 miles an hour,
you start flipping.
Good luck.
Who knows what's going to happen is once
in a car,
I'm going fast on the freeway,
like Tripoli and have all these guys
were on a road trip and a tire popped.
That's crazy.
Oh yeah,
man.
Dangerous itself.
It's just dead.
Yeah.
Very dangerous.
Crazy.
I ran over a,
you know,
those metal things.
Not,
not the,
uh,
the railroad.
When you think of a railroad tie.
I'm not the wooden.
Not Wooden piece,
right.
That's what would that be a metal bar,
the metal stuff that would be a piece of
like a railroad track.
Somebody had left a piece of a railroad
track on the highway,
like a 12 inch section of it and I hit
that thing and it was like someone shot
my tire out with a rifle.
He just my car when my car,
like literally caught air.
It was a small car too.
I think it was my supra caught air,
blew my fucking wheel apart,
like literally blew it apart and blew
the tire.
Half a part two and I was in the middle
of the highway and it was a mile from
the exit and I was gonna pull over and I
was going to call aaa,
but kid I went to high school with,
did that and died.
He got hit by a car.
He was,
um,
on the side of the road and he was
trying to change a tire and a guy just
plowed right into him and killed him.
And I never forgot that.
And I just drove gangster style on a
completely blown out.
Randall.
It was banging and sparking and it
smelled like fire.
It was like bang,
Bang,
Bang.
Just sparks and it's the rubber because
the rubber was like half hanging on,
half hanging off.
It was just ripping and flying around.
When I was driving I drove all the way
to that fucking exit and all the way to
the side.
I just kept driving.
It was chewing up the sidewalk.
It was probably fucking up the road,
like all the asphalt asphalts not that
hard,
you know,
fuck your rooms up there.
Do you remember?
Said?
Yeah,
there,
there was no rim left.
It wasn't a rim anymore.
I mean it was just the whole outside of
it was just completely destroyed.
I fucked up a lot of suspension parts
too,
I think if I remember correctly,
but they towed it and fixed it,
but it was like,
at least I'm alive bitch.
I'm like,
I would,
I would way rather or I would have left
it there and just ran down the side of
the road and made sure I was like way
off to the right.
I'm not staying in my fucking car on the
road.
It's just too goddamn dangerous.
Especially today.
I see so many people fucking on their
phones driving on the highway at night.
We see their face lit up by the phone.
It's so distracting.
You see cops with their lights on
getting hit continuously.
So I mean a normal car.
It's got to happen all the time.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's happening all the time.
But um,
yeah.
So that was the most fucked up thing I
ever drove over in my car.
But God damn,
that was loud.
Like black.
I saw it too,
like last second I was like,
fuck the fuck.
Like,
you know,
you just realize there's not a goddamn
thing you can do if you swerve and you
don't hit that.
I was like,
well,
if I swerve,
I'm probably gonna flip this car or
something fucked up.
It's going to happen.
I'm definitely going to lose control of
it.
I might be able to just ride out this
impact.
That's what I want.
I'm doing,
but
that's nothing.
That's nothing.
You know,
I watched this video once of this.
A car was on a snowy road and they were
driving in one direction and there's a
semi driver in the other direction and
the car in the snowy road starts
fishtailing and they lose control of the
car and they go right into the oncoming
lane and get hit by a semi and literally
disintegrate.
It is one of the best examples of how
fleeting life could be like you're
watching these people that drive in this
car and then it goes sideways and then
they're facing the truck and the truck
hit them head on.
Sixty miles an hour over.
It just destroys the car.
The car just becomes like little pieces
of things that go all up in the air.
It's a.
it's fucked up.
Look up man.
This weekend I did the odd ball comedy
fest in a Detroit,
Chicago and Toronto and Brian Regan has
his own tour bus.
That stuff is crazy because you don't
even feel like you're moving at all.
You're just chilling,
hanging out,
just hanging out in his apartment.
He has got the relocation,
real state of the art one,
like the newest,
newest,
and he helped design it.
All this stuff like he like got to like
play architect with it.
Like I want this there,
I want to counter their chairs there,
make those captain chairs instead of
couches and it was just,
it was like being in the future because
you're moving in a house that doesn't
feel like it's moving.
So does he stay in hotels or did you
just stay in his tour?
Bus Holidays in the tour bus has a
master bedroom,
has everything.
You don't ever need to do anything.
Again,
weird relationship he has with that guy
who drives him around where he hit the
guy that drives them around is a second
generation tour bus driver.
He's been doing it 30 years.
His father was a tour bus driver for all
these big things and he basically bottom
like.
It's like when he's on tour,
that's his guy and he's a super pro so
he knows what he's doing,
like a surgeon and he's cool.
Obviously he doesn't bother him or
whatever.
You know what I mean?
What a weird life it is,
unbelievable,
and it's the best thing ever because you
know how after a shell we have to go
back to the hotel and then the next
morning you have to get up and go to the
airport and that takes an hour and then
you have to spend an hour there early.
He leaves the venue and immediately
outside of whatever the closest back
door is is the door to his bus,
which is the house,
so then you.
You leave the venue in.
You're immediately at your own after
party.
You're immediately where you want to be.
Whoever you invite can come with you,
but you leave then and that driver
drives all night to wherever you want
them to.
When you wake up the next morning in
your bed at your destination,
instead of waking up at a hotel and
having to go to the airport and then
having to get on the plane and then
having to get out of lax or wherever you
are,
you just walk out that door that you
walked in from the venue.
You walk out the door again and you're
at your house.
I realized that this is the actual,
like new goals.
I got new goals.
It's called bus goals,
goals,
trying to sleep.
He slams on the brakes.
You wake up,
doesn't have car accident,
you catch on fire.
Didn't Ralphie have a boss?
Ralphie is a bus.
Ralphie is a mansion.
No.
Yeah,
Ralphie has a bus but this and it's
cool.
But this bus,
I've been on some cool buses.
I'm friends with John Rich who's like a
huge country music star.
Awesome bus.
But this bus,
state of the art
says a bus.
He did the bus thing for awhile.
I had a bus and you would bring the bus
to a movie sets to like as kids can hang
out on the bus.
Bus was dope.
Fully set up and then he drove across
the country in the bus.
And what he did was his family was on
the bus and he was behind them on a
motorcycle
so he could just ride his Harley on the
fucking highway right behind the bus
across the country.
I mean,
she's just living fantasies.
This point.
Can I put a c do on top of my bus?
And uh,
but yeah,
it's crazy you ever worked with Brian
Regan?
Well,
I've done some stuff with him.
He's done this podcast.
I know I've done some gigs with them
back in New York,
like back in the day.
He's a great guy.
He,
it
was so much fun and I've gotten to meet
all my heroes.
Ron White's been hanging out like an
animal at the store,
which is super surreal because it was
him and Brian Regan.
Where are comedy central guys growing
up,
you know,
that's sort of like all you had that
wasn't on Hbo.
So like,
you know,
it was a super surreal weekend because
he was,
he was very ron white,
so you know what I'm talking about.
Like he's down to hang with comedians.
He's funny all the time.
It's not one of those guys that like
shuts down and he was just a blast.
Like he is that guy.
So like if there's ever a dull moment
though,
just he can pretty much say anything.
And it's funny because just sorta like
that,
you know,
and it's just boom,
it's just laying everybody out.
It was a blast.
It was one of those great ones,
like they say,
don't meet your heroes,
but like he was a fun one.
Yeah,
you can meet some of them.
You can meet Ron White.
Yeah.
It's um,
you know,
it's a cool time at the store.
Guys like Ron White hanging out.
Everybody's hanging out there now.
It's crazy.
I told Brian Regan all about it.
I said,
you know,
you have to come because he really
enjoys La.
I don't know.
I don't think he does.
I don't think he really does it if he
does,
I'm sure it's like the will will turn or
something like that.
Well,
when I was talking to him,
he was saying he pretty much just kind
of writes and does the material at his
shows,
you know,
it just writes new shit and does it at
his shows in front of his audiences.
And
I'll tell you this,
it was my second year doing these
oddballs and I've never seen comedians
or myself.
I haven't laughed.
Like I was laughing at him since I was a
child since I,
since I very first started standup.
You know how when you really start and
you're watching guys for the first time
and you're just dying,
she's like,
how are they doing that?
It was like that.
His justice premises,
his delivery is everything.
Like it was surreal to watch every
single joke that he went into.
I thought to myself,
how have I never thought of that?
One of those things where over and over
and over again and you're like,
Whoa,
he's about to talk about that.
I thought only I noticed that you're
watching an amphitheater
continuously.
He's constantly touring to.
Yeah,
I mean Brian's.
He's everywhere,
but that's all he does now.
It's interesting.
This is one of those guys like I feel
like bill burr and Chappelle are always
in the thing.
You know what I mean?
But he is.
I mean,
I'm not saying he's bad or whatever,
but I mean like,
no,
he's fantastic.
Yeah.
You know the differences though,
he's clean and so people think of him as
being not as funny because he's clean
because you go,
oh,
well you can take your kids to go see
Brian Regan.
It doesn't matter.
He's a killer.
Lays them out,
you're like,
don't even notice that he's not clean,
so everybody is clean because he's so
funny.
It's totally irrelevant.
Yeah.
It's just funny,
but there was a lot.
You spend a lot of guys like that.
Like Mitch Hedberg is perfect example
that Mitch Hedberg,
people forget.
It was very clean.
He hardly ever swore and if he did it
was totally unnecessary.
It was just having fun.
Like has jokes.
We're all like surreal Weirdo jokes,
you know?
There's been a lot of people like that,
like Jerry Seinfeld,
perfect example,
just not only was he clean,
like he didn't even ever touch on
controversial subjects.
I had to follow
him at the comedy store a few weeks ago
talking about Mitzi shore and how she
has Parkinson's and she said he wasn't
funny three decades before.
Whoa.
It was unbelievable.
Out of everything I've done in standup
in nine years,
I've never been in a tougher position
than following Jerry Seinfeld.
I always like following good people,
but he just like went off on a rant
about how this lady that owns this club
told me 38 years ago,
whatever it was,
some crazy number.
I know it's more than 30,
the 30 for 36 days.
She told me 37 years ago that I wasn't
funny.
What's the deal with that brow?
You know what I mean?
Like the room was just dying.
It was crazy.
Speaking can many basically dropped the
mic and I did go up there just
horrendous.
Speak it and die.
Tell me about Ann Coulter.
Oh yeah.
That's what I'm dealing with all day.
So the same culture situation.
Culture was at the roast of Rob Lowe.
It wasn't live right now.
It was on last night,
but when did it,
when did they film it?
Last Saturday.
So we'll only a week away.
Yeah.
So what happened?
Well,
you know,
this is the sixth roasts that I've
written for the third one that I've been
a staff writer on and it's always
interesting when someone gets booked,
you know,
what's gonna happen,
blah,
blah blah.
And Ann Coulter was one of the last
bookings that we had and I was excited
to help her and she,
uh,
she didn't want,
she didn't want to do anything that the
writers told her,
you know,
that she sort of had to do,
like to be funny.
And she's like,
she didn't think anything was funny.
So she rewrote everything,
like the script that we originally wrote
anyway,
she bombed really bad.
She bombed really bad.
But what was she trying to avoid?
Like when you said she didn't want to do
what they wanted to do?
Well we wanted her to write.
We had one,
we had stuff in her voice,
like with her angle and a little bit of
self deprecating at the top,
you know what I mean?
Like it was supposed to be like,
Hey,
I'm ann coulter,
you know,
you might be wondering why I'm here at
the Rob Lowe Roast.
It's because it's the first time that
I'm not the most hated person in the
room,
you know,
like sort of like put it off on her
letter and you've got to acknowledge who
you are.
But instead she's like,
Nah,
I don't like them.
I'm not gonna,
not gonna play.
I'm not going to self middle.
I'm gonna Shit on myself.
Suffer House.
Why would I do that?
You know?
No,
no awareness.
There's no.
Those were her exact words,
but she just said she wasn't going to do
that and she would just cut out.
You Go,
you go back and forth via emails and
then all of a sudden all the good stuff
is cut out and there's bad stuff.
And some of the stuff's rewritten.
Did you meet her in real life?
Yeah.
Did you meet her in real life before the
actual roast or the day of?
Uh,
the day of.
I talked to her on the phone five days
out,
which she was okay on that and she's
like laughing at the script.
But then once it's in email she rewrote
it.
It was bad.
But you really think that she's less
hated and Rob Lowe?
No,
no,
not at all.
Oh,
everyone loves rob lowe,
who
was the most hated person in the room
besides her.
Was The joke about Rob Lowe?
Yeah.
The joke is like,
yeah,
now she's saying that she's hated.
She's acknowledged.
Exactly,
but didn't.
She's saying that rob lowe's hated,
so it's a joke,
but it's not really written it.
That part doesn't need to be funny
though.
We just needed her to acknowledge that
she's a piece of shit and she didn't
want to do that.
Instead she came out and literally it's
like you might be wondering why on here
what's it couldn't possibly be to
promote my new book,
and she leans down all awkwardly and
pulls out her shitty book in trump.
We trust.
He pluribus awesome.
And she says,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Her new book is in trump.
We trust.
Yeah,
at.
Wait for it.
He pluribus.
Awesome.
That's like the tag of the book.
She said it and just the roar boos from
the crowd book.
She loves trump.
That trump shit money she wrote.
That is her 11th book.
She's written 11 books was worth a good
amount of money.
Jesus.
What was the purpose of having her on
the roast to begin with?
It seems like the roads have always had,
like,
I kind of like a goat,
you know,
like Jersey shore.
They had the situation on one roast.
We got to hold that back up.
I want to read this description.
Put,
pull up,
make it smaller.
So here we go.
Donald trump isn't a politician.
He's a one man wrecking ball against are
dysfunctional and corrupt establishment.
We're about to see the deluxe version of
the left's favorite theme.
Vote for us,
or we'll call you stupid.
It's the working class against this
smirking class now,
and culture with her unique insight,
candor and sense of humor,
who makes the definitive case for why we
should all join his revolution.
Wow.
She just bent over.
She bent over for the man who might be
king.
Yeah,
she was.
She.
She wants to play that character,
but yeah.
Well,
if he wins and she wrote a book like
that,
she's in deep,
deep,
deep.
She will be the one to defend him every
time there's any sort of a public.
No,
he doesn't like her by the way.
He doesn't like her.
Doesn't like to see in one of the really
funny things is that he changed his
immigration policy,
like tweak the tone of it the day before
that book came out and it's sorta like
mess things up because.
Yeah,
because he's sorta like a,
you know,
office books like all about like,
yeah,
don't let anybody in his zero
immigration.
And he was sorta just like,
you know,
he visited Mexico like out of nowhere,
like the day before her book came out
and she's like,
uh,
you know,
it just wasn't good press for her.
What does he say?
Or seeing the Mexicans or have to leave
and they're going to have to go through
the proper channels in order to legally
immigrate to the United States.
You're going to have to go back to
Mexico first.
The,
he knows.
No one's doing that.
No one's going back to Mexico.
Dude,
stop.
Definitely.
Did you know that?
Um,
who was it that,
uh,
tweeted this,
Pete Dominick tweeted this,
that there is like a literally zero
percent gross migration from Mexico.
Like the amount of people that come over
here from Mexico versus the amount of
people that leave here and go to Mexico,
it evens out.
There's like a zero percent migration.
That sounds like a steady written by a
Mexican.
Well,
I was wondering whether or not it takes
into account illegal immigration and if
it does,
how could they possibly know what the
numbers are?
It seems like they don't.
Otherwise you're watching the people
come in,
you're counting them and then you know
where they are and then you're just
done.
You're like a part of the problem.
You're like letting them come over the
border.
Like how many people come over the
border every day and get away with it a
lot?
Oh yeah.
I know like five people that came over
here from Mexico.
They just come over.
Come over.
Yeah,
I mean I think I would too.
For sure.
I just think
there's.
There's two ways to handle this.
This is what I think.
I think if you want to like go into the
magical mystery world of of impossible
ideas,
the best impossible ideas help Mexico so
much that they don't want to come over
here because it's awesome over there to
like help them figure out how to make
Mexico awesome,
but they're not going to do that because
the best way to get people to work for a
bucket day and some fucking underarmour
factory or Nike factory or whatever they
do down in Japan,
which is totally legal.
You know,
if they want to do that down in Mexico
or Volkswagen.
Yeah.
I mean a bunch of companies make shit
down in Mexico and the reason why they
do it is they bring jobs to impoverished
communities.
These people get a chance to make money
more than they ever would have made on
their own without these plants,
but they're working for significantly
less than they would if they were living
in the United States.
So it gets.
It gets real weird.
It's like,
you know,
yeah.
Is it better for them than it used to
be?
Absolutely.
But is it as good for them as it is here
and fuck?
No.
Well is it okay for a company to keep
people in a position where they're never
going to be in as good a position as
they would if they were working in the
United States with our laws?
Is it okay?
I Dunno.
It's trip.
If you buy an iphone,
you Kinda,
you kinda of a part of the problem.
If you bind sneakers,
most likely you're not making sleek
sneakers in Columbus.
Hyphens in Mexico City,
they make them.
No,
I met some of them.
Did they make some of them in Mexico?
Mexico.
Some of them in China.
What if they jump off Mexico?
No,
because you're fucking hard work and
people,
they're not going to dive off the
building like a pussy.
They're going to finish their job and
they're going to have some Tequila and
party.
Yeah,
they do that.
Mexicans have fun.
They're the wrong people to hate
Mexicans,
to have awesome food.
They're festive.
They're very family oriented there.
I mean,
yeah,
there's drug violence,
but that's just human beings.
Like the Mexican culture is pretty
fucking chill,
you know,
like as far as like having neighbors.
Like,
dude,
you could have your next door.
Neighbors could be like some crazy North
Koreans that want to kill you.
Like if you live in,
in South Korea,
you got real immigration problems,
you've got a real problem with your
border because you're got North Korea
and South Korea.
You're fucking next door neighbors run
by a,
a murderous dictator that's worse.
That's way worse.
What do we got?
We've got beaches,
tacos.
Dan's people cool as fuck.
They like bull fighting.
That's a little weird.
Two.
That's the past.
That's the shit.
I watched an amazing documentary on
Netflix about bullfighting watering.
I sorta want to go see it,
but I want to go to Spain to see it.
I think that the big ones are in Spain.
You're gonna have to do it soon.
I have a feeling they're gonna slowly
make that shit illegal.
People.
There's so much pressure.
Wait till you see the.
Any stadiums filled.
I mean it's like.
No,
I understand,
but there's also a lot of protestors.
Even these European countries or it's
been a tradition,
you know,
it's fucked up way for these animals to
die,
you know,
it is very weird.
I mean occasionally the matador gets it
and that's,
that's something that you don't see in
America.
There's not a single thing that we do
where you have that much of a
possibility of getting mercked by a huge
animal with horns on his head.
This is not.
I mean bull riding I guess Sorta,
but I guess those guys do get stomped.
Yeah,
they do,
but they're not trying to kill the bull.
Right.
It's a totally different kind of an
exchange.
The bull rider is a guy who's just
trying to hang on for eight seconds.
The matador.
I mean that shit will take a while and
they're going to stab the fuck a thing.
People are going to hand them different
swords.
He's going to try to stab it in the back
of the neck and you got a bunch of
people that are helping them to and
they're poisoning that thing and
throwing poison darts into it,
in the,
in it to get like bigger to get more
famous as a matador.
Like you take more chances,
you know there's this thing,
one move where like you just get down on
your knees and spread your legs before
they let the bowl out and your whole
thing is like that first move because it
comes up with the.
You see it coming around the corner when
they release it and you have your back
to the bull,
you are starting like,
yeah,
like down,
not not back to the bowl,
down on your knees and someone's going
to do it that way.
That'd be your back to bowling.
I think that's a little blade.
Wesley snipes.
Jump up and slice it.
Snake off as it comes towards you.
Celebrity.
Matador would be a great show.
Wesley snipes versus a bowl.
Did you see the most recent bull attack
matador thing where it went up?
His asshole.
The horn literally went up,
his asshole tore his insides apart in
this thing has just ragdoll on him with
a horn in his asshole.
I think he died.
Yeah,
he died,
right?
Yeah.
Whoops.
I mean that shit can happen,
but I mean I think they eat the bowl,
but it's just a fucked up way to do it
was like,
I guess.
I guess it's a,
it's a tradition.
You kind of think this is
like a barbaric tradition from days gone
by when people didn't know any better.
It's a very slow death to.
Did they eat all those dead reindeers?
I got electrocuted by lightening
question.
I was thinking about that.
This reindeer good meat.
Yeah,
it's Caribou rain,
deer and Caribou.
Basically the same thing.
It's just different names for it and
Caribou is one of the most delicious of
all game animals.
Apparently.
They're also one of the rare deer where
the females have antlers too,
like the male and the female have
antlers.
They all have antlers is to fight off
wolves apparently.
So the males have antlers to like head
butt each other and I'm like,
what bitch?
But the females I'm antlers to like
protect their children.
Maybe that's just a theory.
Maybe they're all androgynous.
Yeah.
Or they just live it up in the Tundra.
That's just makes hard bitches.
A lot of the women have in Alaska looked
like they could be.
It's Pat.
Even the female theorists are giant
lesbians.
It's a hard life up there for Caribou.
Plus they're all on this migration.
So,
uh,
when you see Caribou's marching across
the field,
you'll see like maybe even hundreds of
them,
but they're all online.
Like your father.
There's a line of them.
So you see them coming from like a mile
away.
So you just get in position,
find out where they're going to be.
Go down past where there are right now.
They seem to be going in this direction.
Sit Down,
wait,
set the gun up.
And what,
what?
Let them walk close.
That's the people.
Do they let him walk?
Close and bubbling.
Blam blam were eating ham.
Delicious Ham.
So good though.
Caribou's delicious.
So 300 of them died because they were
all in a rainstorm and they were all on
wet grass and the electricity hit the
lightening bolt hit and they all got
cooked.
Oh,
that would have been crazy video.
It says five still walking around.
When this showed up,
they had to put them down.
Why?
Because they saw too much crazy shit.
PTSD,
Vietnam vets.
Fuck man.
It just look what they did to my.
They were all sad.
Caribou.
Who lightening is fucking crazy.
You really stop and think about the fact
that there are these things that float
in the sky and out of them come
impossibly powerful beams of electricity
that split trees down the middle and
Cook people.
My friend remy who was talking about
earlier where his dad owns that a lie,
next place he got hit by lightning when
he was in high school and he.
He talked about it on the podcast and he
said it was just like you didn't even
realize what happened until after it
happened way after it happened.
It was just trying to come to try to
figure out why the fuck he was on the
ground and like what happened?
I could just shut your whole system.
Just gets
Barbara from Youngstown,
Ohio.
We had this old legendary guy called
green guy and he got struck by
lightening as a kid and literally was
green forever.
What?
Some green dude.
The real guy.
Yeah.
Guy That was just green.
Maybe it was purple.
It's been a long time.
But purple guy or green guy.
Here it is.
Go Green Guy.
Green man.
That's him.
Where's that photo of western
Pennsylvania,
but that's next to me.
I mean eastern a job.
What's that photo?
Beaver falls.
Yeah.
He looks like snoopy or something.
Is that he lost his face.
Is that what it is?
This is a black and white picture,
so you can't really tell that he's green
version of the story so you can read it
or he lost his eyes.
Nose and one arm.
Oh yeah,
he got electrocuted.
That's what it is.
There was a,
um,
a store that I seen on some me,
I believe it was a youtube video the
other day of this guy was hiking and he
saw a bear that was dead,
his giant bear,
and he went up to it and poked it with
his knife and immediately exploded in
electricity.
He lost his arm,
lost his vision last,
I think it lost his hearing.
My wife lost one of his legs,
just got hit with an impossible bolt of
electricity because the bear had dug
into a power wire and bitten into the
power wire and he just,
by touching it with his knife,
he just tapped right into that power and
blew his arm completely off of his body.
Yeah.
I've seen a few of those videos.
And what's crazy about electricity also
that a lot of people don't factor in is
that it sticks you right where you are.
I once got electrocuted really badly at
my grandma's house when I was a kid.
Uh,
she,
you know,
she had like these old old type of light
bulbs that were like old fluorescents
and you know,
little metal handle on the sink.
And I remember I grabbed the handle and
blind and you can't get your hand on the
handle.
That's the thing with electricity is
you're stuck.
So you're like,
this sucks and you can't pull away.
You're trying,
but it sticks you there.
So I imagine like a lot of people just
had creepy fucking deaths from
electricity.
Can't get away from it.
It keeps you there.
Yeah.
Electric fence.
When I was a kid I was trying to climb
up this fence to hang out with some cows
or horses or something.
And I grabbed onto it and was electric
and I was like,
I couldn't let go.
I remember just,
and it's like five seconds,
but it feels like for ever electricity.
So bizarre.
The fact that we have electrical signals
in our own body and that electricity is
in.
Everyone's like this room,
I think about how much you take
electricity for granted,
but how much it's shaped modern life.
It's very rare.
You're not around electricity,
but electricity itself is only like a
couple of hundred years old.
Like as an invention,
like people harnessing it.
Like what the Ben Franklin when,
when was that experiment?
If you had to guess when there's been
Franklin had that kite where the key key
hanging from it?
17.
If you had to guess 60,
17,
16,
I would say.
Wow.
That's a crazy one to think of.
Eighteen 76.
Well he was like 1776 guy.
Right.
So he was a part the uh,
he was one of the founding fathers.
So 1750 2:17,
52.
This motherfuckers out there with a
kite.
First of all,
how ball or must America been back then?
Just.
No,
no lights.
Benjamin Franklin was a beast
man.
He did like a lot of stuff.
Smoked a lot of weed.
Is that true?
Yep.
I just made it up.
That's from like dazed and confused or
something.
How high.
They're huge.
Pothead.
Each other.
Jamie,
what'd you say?
That wasn't how high that was.
His Bong at the end of the method man
movie
probably was a pothead because
I think he grew.
It didn't make sense for sure.
Yeah.
If you look Google Ben Franklin weed,
I'm pretty sure he.
Not only did he grow it,
I think he talked about smoking it dazed
and confused.
There was that whole scene about how he
grew weed and had been frankly,
man,
he agree with.
They all were getting high back then.
Of course,
they knew about it.
If they knew about it,
they were using.
It just didn't have the stigma does
today.
America's founding fathers loved hamp.
Yeah.
Didn't he write something?
George Washington wrote something about
it as well.
I sort of saw it said that he had a hemp
paper mill.
Franklin did.
Well,
this is back when they,
you know,
the whole thing that fucked hemp up was
the cotton gin.
When Eli Whitney came up with a cotton
gin,
it made it easier for them to process
cotton because before they had to use
slaves and it was a.
It was a real pain in the ass and the
same thing with hemp,
like what would they had to use with
hemp was they used to have to beat it
down to get to the fiber.
He used to have to smash it and like it
was a like a long laborious process,
but that's what they use for everything
they did.
The reason why canvas is called canvas
is from the word cannabis.
Hemp is what the actual paper that's
used to make canvas.
Like when you make a painting you see
like the Leonardo Da Vinci paintings or
Mona Lisa or something like that.
That stuff is all on hemp.
Like they made them on him.
Like one of the first drafts of the
declaration of independence.
They wrote it on hemp.
Hemp paper was real common,
but then they came up with a more
economically efficient way to process
continent.
Hemp fell off.
Then when slavery became abolished,
hemp really fell off because it wasn't
economically feasible until the 19
thirties than the 19 thirties.
They invented this thing called the
decorticator and the decorticator
allowed them to like really effectively
and almost instantly processed the hemp
fires.
This group,
big crazy machine crank and as soon as
that came out,
that's when William Randolph hearst
started running all those ads about
black people and Mexicans smoking
marijuana and raping white women.
It was all just to try to stop the hemp
industry.
They turned it into a marijuana thing
and we're still suffering to this day.
Amazing.
You can grow hemp now,
right?
In the United States.
Some spots on it getting yet.
Well,
we're.
We're being real careful with being real
careful with this marijuana thing
because well,
one day we're for sure going to get
involved in either Colorado or
Washington state for sure.
Why wouldn't we sell like super healthy?
We'd will find it,
but it's not.
This is just to touch and go right now
with legalization,
it's too sketchy.
Federal government is still telling
people that they can't get guns.
This is the most recent ruling that you
can't have a gun if you have a medical
marijuana card,
which is fucking insane because you
could drink booze all day long.
Excuse me.
You could take pharmaceutical pills,
opiates all day long if you want it to.
You can do a bunch of different mind
altering things and still legally
possess a gun,
but you can't smoke pot if there's any
drug that you should have while you're
high.
It's when you have a gun,
rather it's pot.
If there's any drug,
it's pot because that's the drug that's
gonna make you go.
Now I shoot anybody,
man.
Right.
You know,
like all the other ones are gonna
displace your reality.
All the other ones are going to put you
in a position where you're,
you're probably gonna feel less
inhibition and you're,
you're probably more likely to shoot
someone if you're drunk,
someone.
Sure.
On pills.
Crazy fucks.
Yeah.
That whole pot things messed up.
So,
uh,
back to Ann Coulter.
Yeah.
So this silly bitch.
So what does she try to do?
She tries to write our own jokes.
Then.
Yeah.
You know this,
you know,
like I worked with Martha Stewart for
the Bieber Roast.
She crushed it,
crushed it.
The first thing she said to me is,
I want to kill as hard as I can.
So Hook it up and I'm like,
Stuart's done time.
That's what I want you to do.
Yeah.
She's the best ever.
She's been in the pokey.
She stands shit at a level and culture
where they're privileged lifestyle of
white people everywhere she goes.
Correct.
And so ann coulter basically says that,
you know,
she doesn't like this joke.
She doesn't like that joke.
She writes this,
she puts a pitch for a book at the top.
First off,
she was like a third to last.
She was second.
So Rob Lowe,
it went Ann Coulter,
Jeff Ross,
Rob Lowe,
and to show,
right.
So all these people went before Ralph
Masaccio,
Nikki Glaser,
Pete Davidson,
Jimmy Carr,
a blah blah blah,
blah blah.
Anyway,
and she got lit up and I mean big time,
Peyton Manning,
jewel,
everybody.
They'd hit everybody on the day as you
know,
because you always make fun of everybody
at a roast of course,
and then you get the main target at the
end of your thing.
But when people went in on Ian Coulter,
they went in hard,
very hard.
Like Jimmy Carr had this one joke which
I loved,
which I'm going to completely
destroy right now because I.
I don't know exactly how he set up,
but it was something like Ann Coulter is
here and you ugly ratchet faced piece of
shit scum bucket.
It's like something like that.
Just like five insulting words just gag
that I can't get a gang.
And he goes,
you are one of the most insufferable
human beings on the planet,
but it's not too late.
You can change.
You could kill yourself.
And the crowd just home.
I mean just everybody hated her,
so she was great to have on the Deus.
Wow.
She could have killed me and Mike
Lawrence,
who's a huge pro wrestling fan and Sarah
Tiana,
who's an old school pro wrestling fan.
We looked at her like,
wow,
we can write her as a heel.
She'll own it.
It'll be great.
We're all going to look like superstars
because we were able to make ann coulter
funny,
but instead halfway through the week we
realize like,
oh no,
she doesn't get it and she wants to do
this and you don't want to scare away
from not being on the roast.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to be like,
hey,
you're going to,
you're going to do terrible because then
they know there's a chance that you
might not do it.
And we wanted her there because you
know,
you're gonna show she's going to do
good,
great.
Everybody's gonna Shit on her.
But also,
you know,
worse comes to worse.
People love a train wreck.
And this was a train wreck.
Super trainer.
There was
no,
this was like a gift of a train wreck.
It just going to watch it.
Boom,
boom.
She was terrible.
And the one thing comedy central did do,
which is hilarious,
is the reaction shots that they chose
for her jokes,
like when she was on stage,
uh,
are hilarious.
Like it just cuts to just.
People just started just studying.
Well,
she made her bones in the safest,
softest world,
which is the world of like political
commentary where there's five different
people and everybody's shouting over
everybody and you don't have to say
anything that's really relevant and
especially her because she's just a
button pusher.
She's a white lady,
button pusher and she gets up there and
she says crazy things like if Canada
doesn't like it will invade them.
She says stupid shit like that.
She doesn't even mean,
you know,
and like this is what she does.
She pushes buttons and Bill Maher calls
her his friend and they laugh together.
Ha.
And she lives in the soft world.
That world that she stepped into is not
just one of the hardest worlds,
but for a person like her to go on after
someone like Jimmy Carr and get washed
and then attempt to plug her book and
all that Jazz,
like I bet she has no idea what the
average person's perception of her is
because she's dealing with that bubble,
that fucking talk show and shit.
Crazy idiots.
Yeah.
That weird bubble where she's kind of
legitimate in that bubble and you know,
she's the button pusher.
Oh,
here it was crazy.
And you know,
she thinks she's wacky
and another thing is,
you know,
one of the main things that are roast is
when you get made fun of you should
laugh.
Yeah.
Because it shows that you have a sense
of humor.
That's like the main thing.
That's why trump did it.
Now he's could be president.
Charlie Sheen did it.
Pro Trump can be president because he
did a roast.
Hey
Justin Bieber's the number one artist in
the world.
Oh,
it's all gross.
If you can handle the road trying to
talk you.
I'm trying to get you to want to do a
Joe Rogan rose.
That's what we want out of here.
Joe Rogan.
So when Ann Coulter does
this,
I'm changing the subject immediately
looking at that.
I'm not doing.
I'm not being mean to you and I don't
want you being mean to me,
but when you do this roast with Ann
Coulter,
what happens when people are joking
about her?
Oh yeah.
Well,
that's the best thing is she did not
laugh at anything about her and she
always just had the same look on her
face and it stuck.
That's it.
Every single joke like you just put in
just basically,
hey,
we want you to die.
That's the look that it would cut back
too.
And the crowd when you're watching it on
tv,
that's funny because she's not laughing
and he called her hatchet,
faced a ratchet hatchets or oh,
horse face got Peyton manning said,
I'm not the only champion up here.
Ian Coulter won the Kentucky Derby a
couple of weeks ago.
Peyton manning annihilated.
Now that's a guy who,
you know,
and Sarah Tiana was really hands on with
him and you know,
he got his script,
made tweaks,
studied it all week.
He put it in prompter himself.
He's with the prompter guy,
you know,
before the show,
making sure that every word is perfect.
Exactly where he wants it.
And he stole the show.
Him and Joel were the two best jewel.
The singer.
Yes.
No Shit.
She was so great.
Really.
One of the things she said right at the
top of her set,
you know,
she's like,
as a feminist,
I can't agree with everything that I've
heard up here tonight,
but as a person who hates Ann Coulter,
she annihilated.
She's so good.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I wrote for her
that was a sort of the room a hands on.
Ella was a guy named George Ryan Black,
good roast writer.
Uh,
some other people,
they're smart Tiana's in on that too.
Such a smart move to pair them up with
comics,
coach them through it.
Oh,
well,
I mean then they wouldn't have a chance
on their own.
I know,
but I mean as far as entertainment
value,
like you could have been a gross
clusterfuck of you got to see their own
real ideas.
But yeah,
it's definitely better.
And you know,
there were,
there were reading an awesome prompter.
It's show business.
So you would say that Martha Stewart is
like the best ever.
I mean,
you know,
I'm a little bit biased,
but yeah,
she's the best ever roaster.
She's just
freakishly great human being at
everything she does.
She's the best.
She's a baller dude.
Not only did she have more prison time
than all those other people in the day
is like snoop and shy.
She's just a Keller.
She killed.
She's a billionaire,
she's a assassin.
They put her in jail for some weird shit
to.
Right.
Was it like knowledge of a stock sale or
something like that?
Insider trading.
How does that work?
So if you say,
if you have a stock,
okay,
in,
you know,
you're,
you're working in some company like,
hey dude,
I'm just letting you know right now,
uh,
we're about to sell,
sell,
sell.
So if you want to get out,
get out now.
And I'm like,
Oh shit,
thanks dude.
I'm getting out.
And then I do that.
I'm supposed to just sit by and not do
that and lose money.
Like how does that work?
Can you tell me the,
some
shit's going down and I should bail out
immediately and I don't bail out.
I lose all my money.
Then I got to stay out of jail.
Is that how it works?
I'm pretty sure.
Like you just can't be super blatant
about it.
Like the SEC or whatever it is,
a,
I can't remember what it is,
but a securities and exchange council.
Yeah.
So they commissioned like if they see
that you just sold millions of dollars
worth of stocks that day or two before
something absurd happens with that
company,
then you know,
it's sort of blatant.
Did you ever see it?
Stuff that's connected to nine slash 11.
There's another nine slash 11 thing.
So how many people sold American
Airlines stock?
How many people predicted that American
Airlines stock would crash and it's all
like Illuminati type bloom bloom.
Not Bloomberg.
What are those people?
Bilderberg Bilderberg characters.
Yeah.
Selling American airline stock.
It's probably bullshit.
Did you ever snopes that
says false,
but wait a minute.
I saw this documentary on Youtube,
put pay.
What does it say on September 11th,
blah,
blah.
The operation and taking years to plan.
Was it saying Jamie false status false.
Only to delay the takeoff,
blah,
blah.
It was a long ass paragraph.
I'm sorry this wasn't spirit airlines
that went into shit.
I wish it was.
Spirits are really airline.
They're the worst.
What spirit airline?
It's like all the planes that get
graffitied and stuff.
It just didn't turn in the spirit.
Airline.
Goodwill,
goodwill airline.
Yeah.
It's like they get like pushed started
and shit.
They're terrible.
You have to pay just to print out your
your itinerary ticket and you have to
pay per bag.
Like any bag.
Your purse is a bag fee.
They would charge you for your fanny
pack dude.
Yeah.
They'd be like,
what are you doing?
Well,
there was a time where the lady told me
that I had to take it off and put under
the seat.
Your Fanny Fanny to count.
Oh,
weren't you the one that told me that
you couldn't use bluetooth headphones on
a plane.
I use them all the time.
I've never been told anything.
You're not supposed to.
According to the lady that talked to the
guy who was sitting next to me,
she said he couldn't do it.
You can't do it,
sir.
Are Those Bluetooth?
You're going to have to take them off.
Different Lady.
Not the same lady.
My goodness.
Let's see.
But one person ever has told me I have
to take the fanny pack off and put it
under the seat.
Wait,
that is so stupid.
It's like connected to me since your
belt.
It's like it's just a cook.
Top of pocket.
Yeah.
Can I just put it in my pocket and you
dropped it in my pocket?
Yeah.
I stuffed my fanny pack
being a cunt.
But we've all seen that,
you know?
Yeah.
People remember that Airbus that used to
take you to Columbus.
What was that bust?
It was Airbus.
There's called Airbus wasn't jet blue?
No,
no it wasn't jet blue airlines called
airpod there.
But yeah,
it was like $40 million when we.
Once we
took this shit once and the guy fucked
up his landing and had to start all over
again.
He went down and then pulled out and we
go back up again.
I was like,
this motherfucker just had a panicky tie
at that happened to me a few months ago.
God.
But it was like,
you know,
$40 a ticket so cheap.
And there was a direct flight,
which they don't have that they've one
direct flight to Columbus,
Ohio nowadays.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why I had that happen to me a few
weeks or months ago or something.
And um,
and it was flying back home to la and
that was not cool.
It's a scary thing because you're,
you get used to landing your first
whatever,
20,
30 flights.
They're like,
well we're landing,
look out.
But then you get so used to it that,
you know,
what happens,
it's kind of a jerk a little bit.
But what,
what's crazy is that to get it back up
after going down,
like they have to go full steam all the
way.
Engines that are normally are actually
pretty chill because like a bird,
they sort of just,
you know,
you don't have to go full blast.
But when they do go full blast shit gets
crazy and they really had to do that
there.
I mean when you're,
we are down like we are very close to
landing but he was coming in too fast.
He said afterwards you just hear bond
on,
on Don,
like engines and all of a sudden
everything's shaking and you're like,
like that.
They had to like really pull apart.
It was scary man.
Rice.
Yeah.
One of those,
like one out of every.
Whatever.
Thousands.
That probably that happens too.
There was a trump plane that didn't have
the landing gear pop out once.
Remember when trump had an airlines?
Trump airlines.
Do you remember that?
No.
Trump ad trump airlines and they were
landing and the landing gear didn't come
down.
So they skid in like the bottom of the
plane,
just scraped against the ground.
Sparks were flying.
Yeah.
Trump airlines.
Donald trump.
He had that airlines when he was younger
than me.
Like this motherfucker's been.
He's been rich for a long ass time.
Look at them there.
Donald J dot trump.
Is that him in the police car?
That's Bobby Kennedy.
Is it?
Um,
so 29th of September.
You and I are in Columbus.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
The Fun at the palace theater.
And then we're at the tower theater in
Philly on October first.
And I'm at Boston's Wilbur theater.
October eighth.
Oh my goodness.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
Are you filming something there?
I'm going to try to.
Yeah,
thinking about it.
It's just something we'll see.
We'll see what it turns out.
It shows you doing that night to this
one.
Just one.
One in and out.
Whoa.
Easy Breezy.
You can film it in my helmet.
Yeah,
I got another spot.
That's good pot.
Who knows what can happen while you were
well received last time you were there
with me.
Yeah.
Bunch of savages there.
That's my
city man as the people that like it.
Hard,
continuous rough.
No oohs.
And aahs Gacaca,
Gacaca Gacaca.
Plus you're going to be there in
October,
which is like the last burst of
excitement before the freeze,
like in November and December and
January and February and then march
people start coming back to life and
then guess where I'm going?
October 18th.
One bitch place I've been to with you
before.
We saw a little lady get kicked in the
head place called Australia like I'm
headlining,
which shows all by myself.
Like a big boy.
We did see a lady get ahead,
Sydney,
Melbourne and Brisbane.
Beautiful of Australia or the end of
October in Australia.
Dude.
Yeah,
we did see or get kicked in the head.
We did.
Are you going to that same place that we
went to in Melbourne?
I'm not exactly sure.
The venues.
I know I'm doing the comedy store in
Sydney.
You ever done that?
The comedy store in Sydney?
I did do,
yeah.
I did it with Ari.
We did a show at a theater and then on
Sunday we came back and did A.
I think what we did was the fights were
Sunday because the fights,
we're a day ahead,
but there were Sunday in the morning and
so that day we contacted the comedy
store and said,
Hey,
we want to do a show.
So we decided to do a show that night.
That's what we did.
So yeah,
I definitely did it.
It's nice little club.
I'm super excited because I guess like
that's the beginning of their summer,
something at the end of October.
I don't think it gets cold though.
I don't really get it as a joke like
summer,
winter.
It's a joke,
it's always warm,
like Australia,
like Sydney's pretty much perfect
whether they say it's like the Dallas of
Australia feel like,
like a show or the city.
The city of Dallas.
How did he remember that TV show?
But they,
um,
what do they call them?
Cashed up.
Bogans.
Do you want to cash out?
Bogan is.
You're going to have to learn this
terminology.
A cashed up.
Bogans is like a really rich redneck,
like a.
If a guy in Dallas had like a,
a,
a jeep wrangler with fucking 45 inch
tires and a light bar on the roof.
And,
and he's driving by the club with music
plan and he's got a rolex on with
diamonds on it,
but he's obviously trash that,
that's a cashed up Bogan in America.
Get it.
That makes sense.
I feel like there's gonna be some cashed
up bogans at some of my shifts.
They'll definitely be there for sure.
They're going to know you.
They're going to have woody think about
Cyborg.
Might she going to fuck you?
You know,
often I get that by the way,
just randomly I was at the grocery store
the other day and someone hit me with
that.
You better look out and at the UFC on
Saturday.
I got it a couple times.
Actually.
It just got to find her and take a
picture with her.
He totally would make the Internet
explode.
He's everything to get you in a
headlock.
Take a picture.
She could put me in a headlock.
I'll grab her deck and squeeze that
mother fuckers.
You think
that this one?
Come on.
Good Lord.
Amen.
You got it.
You got a shot at a the joker.
Now that jared Leto it Kinda.
They didn't enjoy him as the joker.
I thought he'd look great.
He's a wonderful actor.
I don't know what went wrong,
but he's not.
It's not really working out for America.
Yeah,
there's a chance I'm.
I'm totally ready.
If you want to help me produce it,
we could do it.
Dude.
The one somebody made put that,
they put that head on a better joker
body for that thing that he just
instagrammed and it's a better version
of it,
but I really want to do it.
Yeah,
that's true.
Squad movie was not well received.
I didn't see it when I saw that was
fucking good.
Hell or high water
dude.
It's really good.
A Western right?
Yeah.
It's Jeff Bridges.
And um,
what is the named Ben Cohen?
Isn't the guy's name the Ben Foster?
Is that Ben Foster who's a really good
actor?
He's been in a gang of movies.
He's like,
one of those guys just steals movies in
the background.
You know what?
He was awesome in one of my favorite
vampire movies ever.
I know it sounds ridiculous.
Assigned a 12 year olds,
but 30 days of night,
do you ever see 30 days of night?
There is him and that other dude,
the star wars.
Do Captain Kirk,
the new Captain Kirk.
Good fucking movie,
man.
Good fucking movie.
Fun.
I saw.
Don't breathe the other day in theaters.
And that's a good one too.
What's that?
It's about a bunch of kids that like go
around and steal stuff from houses and
then they find out that there's this old
Vietnam vet who,
uh,
who won a huge settlement and they have
a feeling that they,
that he probably has it in cash and they
show up to his house and you know,
he's blind.
It turns out.
So they're like,
Ooh,
he's blind.
This is going to be fucking great.
Well,
the catch is he can hear you and he can
smell you.
And whoa,
shit gets crazy.
Color is really good.
And who is he a bad motherfucker?
I don't know,
but I've been seeing him in my
nightmares and picturing his head poking
in my bedroom door lately.
That movie Kevin Smith Made Red State,
I think it was called,
where he was like,
he was the preacher.
Oh,
that guy's an excellent.
What is his name?
I'll look it up.
I find out his name.
That guy is excellent.
He's so scary.
Have you ever see red state?
Like,
do you see that now?
Do you see that one there were next to
the one that says don't breathe where
he's just walking by.
Alert me.
Fuck,
don't you spoil.
But he's blind.
So Imagine Shanti.
Why don't you spoiled?
Well,
you got to see it.
You got to see that his death,
the guy from.
That's not the same guy.
That's a different guy.
That's the guy from Avatar.
Is he the guy from Avatar?
He's the marine from Avatar.
Yeah.
So you're thinking of a different guy,
but you also have to see death proof.
You have.
You have to make up for that because
that's all about stunt cars and like
Kurt Russel kills it in this movie.
I feel like I told you it's like 28.
You have told me,
Brian,
I love it.
Made me never put my legs up on the
outside the window.
When you're in the room,
there you go.
Saw Jungle Book,
right?
Yeah.
I didn't like it.
You didn't like?
No,
no.
He's a guy from avatar.
Not what I said.
Steven Lang.
That's who.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker to those guys.
Excellent.
He's excellent in everything.
Kills it.
And he's one of those guys
that you just see in the background.
But uh,
Ben Foster,
that's his name,
right?
That 30 days and night performance.
That's when I first found out about him.
He played like the vampire familiar.
They had these vampires who would go to
Alaska because it wouldn't get.
You wouldn't get light out for a month,
you know,
there's like spots in Alaska where they
have like a never ending winter.
Do you ever Work Alaska?
No.
Dude,
you got.
We got to do a Gig in the summer in
Anchorage.
So it take me a trip now.
We need some more.
It's hard enough for me.
I can't hold your hand,
but fishing is easy.
Fishing in Alaska is fucking awesome to
go.
Salmon fishing and they do shows at
night.
You come out,
he'd do a midnight show.
It's 2:30 in the morning.
Go outside.
It's light out.
That's cool.
Slight.
It's just barely gets dark.
It gets dark for like the tiniest amount
of time,
but it's not really dark.
It gets like 7:30 PM dark and then it
becomes light again.
It's real weird.
I like it
that those are my hours that night as
well.
P when the sun's up for me.
Yeah.
Alaska is cool as fuck to anchorage and
particular people up there are super
nice,
like normal,
like fun.
You can hang out with them and talk to
them and they're.
They're very.
They're hardy people.
You know what I mean?
Like there's not a lot of pussies that
live up there.
You just really can't.
You really can't be a pussy and survive
in Atlanta in Alaska.
It's not the way the people are and it's
not the way the environment is like.
In order to survive in that environment,
you've got to be a self sustaining
person.
You've got to be able to change a tire.
You got to be able to dig yourself out
of a snow storm.
You got to be able to start a fire.
He might have to make a nice tent,
one of those ice Igloos to survive.
That's where jewels from she is.
Do you know her family?
Is the those people that are on that
reality show?
Yeah.
Somebody had the joke like they're like
the Kardashians.
If they were freezing,
she seems very smart too.
Jewel eminent and telling you,
man,
this was the one.
Like she,
I mean her and Peyton both like,
but like for example,
one of the cool things just like doing
sound check earlier in the afternoon.
She's just,
there was a part where like they had to
reload the prompter or something like
that.
She's just doing a run through,
but she did her performance with a
guitar in her hand and she would only
play in between while like people are
dying of laughter to
stop and she would start her next joke.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
What a great idea.
I mean if you have all the writers of
the roasts,
the laughing,
then you did it,
you know what I mean?
Because we've,
we've been laughing about these jokes
for a week already.
So we're watching you.
You're a third time saying them and
worse still cracking up.
Then
what did you think about roast battle
being on television?
Were you happy with the way it came out
or did you feel like it was too big?
And.
I love it.
I think that it's going to get better.
I feel like that's like UFC one.
You know what I mean?
If that makes sense.
Because I think that it should be
regular.
I think that it should get bigger.
I think they shouldn't just make it a
once a year special event.
I want to see it every week.
I want to see it get bigger and breathe
and let it grow and get the cameras
right often.
Should they have Ralphie may back.
I don't think Ralphie,
we'll do it anymore.
Do you think that they like the way
they're doing it right now and these big
environments,
do you think that it takes anything away
from it?
Like don't you think that like I was
like,
I was watching it and I'm like looking
at where the judges are and the
performers are and everything's all so
lit up and I'm like,
this is not the belly room.
Like part of the beauty of roast battle
is how intimate it is.
You're preaching to the choir on that
one.
Why don't they just do it in the belly
room?
Air Preaching.
I mean,
I'm the guy that literally like,
I mean I've been annoying,
you know,
Jeff and Brian and everybody about this
since they started eight years ago.
I literally was going,
you should be doing with this show what
we're doing with kill Tony and just get
it out there.
I mean,
and have.
If they had,
if they put that thing on the Internet,
that would be huge,
huge and people would be killed.
Be you get up.
You become a bigger fan as you see it
more and you learn the characters more.
I mean there's like literally like 75
UFC analogies with this thing with roast
battle because you know there's
different styles and all this stuff and
you sorta have to be good at everything.
You have to be able to hit a rebuttal
and you have to be able to just do a
joke right in the pocket and you know,
it's timing and execution and
haters.
Table Two,
it's been,
it's been like clipped.
It's been edited.
It's been censored.
It's not the roast battle that we know
because it's kind of like the TV version
of a wave didn't make sense.
The racist stuff that scaple says is so
ridiculous and over the top.
What's so hilarious.
Certainly some things aren't gonna make
it to comedy central.
They already have a limit to.
They should have just done it on youtube
from the jump.
Totally.
Where the podcasts,
you know you can download the podcast.
So that's that deaf squad and that's
pretty roast battle.
It's called verbal violence.
So we have the roast battle uncensored
on there so you can hear all the easier.
Everything.
Yeah.
How can you just talk about that?
Play the roast battles?
Yeah.
It's called verbal violence.
We're on like a lot of episodes.
We've been doing it for awhile.
How come you never talk about that?
I always talk about it.
I've never heard you talk about that
once.
Yeah.
I have literally never heard you talk
about a podcast where you take all the
roast battles.
Yeah,
put it online.
It's the roasters all know they're being
put online.
Oh yeah.
It's been on for over a year.
It's,
you know,
Brian Moses and Jamie,
you know what,
coach t record them all or it sounded
pretty good.
Coach t does a real good job on it.
They,
they,
they is something like if Kim,
they'll have Kim as a guest can congdon
then they'll interview her about her
battle and they'll play the whole
battle.
And then uh,
so they,
they make it like special events.
So it's not like last night's is gonna
be on there.
They just pick out all the good ones.
I think they,
they,
they interview the people and they'll
reflect on the battles that they don't
play the whole
also the whole way through.
Yeah.
They don't play all of them now.
Like they'll pay,
they'll play the whole thing and then in
between interrupted literally just edits
it and does whatever he wants.
It cuts in and out of it.
So it's good.
It's good for podcasts because they see,
they kind of have to explain some of the
battles because a lot of the battles are
inside jokes and stuff and so that,
that's why they have like kind of cuts
in between where they talked about how
you film it.
Uh,
they did.
They film it on periscope and she put it
on Youtube.
Uh,
I think,
I don't know why they don't do it.
It's something that they're allowed to
do that anymore.
Yeah.
With the comedy central deal in new
thing.
Yeah.
But they could have they been doing
this.
That's what I'm saying is they don't.
Then I don't even think.
I don't think these networks get it yet,
that if they had,
if they had built a huge built in
following,
then you get those numbers when they
switch over,
those people are always going to go find
the TV show.
Well,
they figured it out.
What this has done happening.
Yeah.
They figured it out with red show
already show started out as a comedy
central Internet show,
which was basically uncensored and had
much longer stories like Joe.
He could tell like a 10 minute story or
something on that,
whereas now everything has to fit into
those commercial breaks,
so they're editing a lot of stories,
you know,
they chopped stories up and they short
numb and take a little of this out and
take a little of that out.
The best way is to see him live,
you know,
especially roast battle.
Same thing with the actual roast to.
I wish that it was more alive and you
would see like the highest and the lows
because it makes the highs a lot better.
Why don't they do them live?
Want to just have a live event?
Is it too difficult to film a live TV
event?
It's expensive,
right?
There's a lot more expensive if they
just get to go in and really perfect it.
Like in that little bit that I did watch
last night,
I,
you know,
Joel Gallon,
the Aep of that roast who's done every
single roast,
all the MTV video awards,
like he's the guy,
he's a genius and to get to see the
reaction shots that he does match them
up with that.
You can only get like halfway there
live,
but to see,
you know,
you get more bang for your buck because
you get the joke,
then you get the reaction from the
person who was made fun of.
Then you get the audience and like if
you match all those things up,
right,
you get the joke reaction,
boom.
You have your laughing at like four
things at once.
So I think going in and doing the
surgery to that probably benefits the
show,
but still I think that's too long of a
turnover a week.
She'd be like the next night or
something they could do that.
Tony's another show
works best in that little room.
It's great in the big room,
but it's,
it's just not as good.
We're getting better at it though.
We've been doing every other Monday in
the main room and it's getting big and
man cool.
We got Pat Reagan and Jeremiah Watkins
in is just has a different feeling when
you do the bigger ones.
It's getting bigger and better.
We're getting better at it,
but what do you prefer?
It gets really?
Honestly,
I sorta like what we're doing right now,
we really should just take over Mondays
in the main room and commit to it and
have special ones,
you know,
like a chill one,
be in the belly room once in a while,
just a throwback episode because I'm
starting to fall in love with the main
room and I think that if we keep doing
it there,
it's just going to keep getting bigger
and to have the chance of having 400
people every Monday at 8:00 PM,
like have it be like a fuck Monday's
show pretty much.
Which it's sort of turning into like we
had like 100 people that are on our last
night.
You got this amazing.
Now with dom I rera the old is the only
guest announced October.
I was perfect and murder just murder the
whole time.
Do you feel like there's something extra
creepy about watching so many bomb in
front of 80 people though?
Because like there's a feeling in the,
in the belly room when someone's eating
a plate of shit in the belly,
it's a different feeling.
You hear their heartbeat.
It's so fucked up that you smell them.
Smell the fear,
you smell their insecurities.
You see the sweat start to put more on.
Why do fuck stole that joke?
Who stole that idea?
Why didn't someone steal the idea?
Oh,
the kill Tony.
I wouldn't say stolen.
I mean we'll see what happens,
but according to some of our friends in
New York,
like the guy who's doing it's cool and
like wouldn't do that type of thing.
Who's at Ron Bennington?
It's an innocent guy,
it seems very cool.
What do you know?
What I've heard though,
it's,
it's actually a company that just takes
a lot of west coast is ideas like roast
battles.
They made like a generic version of
roast battle afforded in east coast.
Yeah.
And so they just kind of picking and
choosing what you,
what they want to steal and they rebrand
it.
But you know,
I,
I was upset the first day or so,
but like,
like,
like Tony said,
let's just see what happens because it's
a big joker.
Sin and a couple other people were like,
you know,
like I got like,
I think Ari hit me up and it's like Yo,
just laying a Bennington guys.
Cool.
Yeah,
let it die out.
And I'm like alright you got me because
I love those guys.
So I mean if they're saying that and you
know,
we're basically like others across the
country.
It's sketchy though is because Joe Rogan
podcast has been on serious so you know,
for like the last couple of years,
I don't know if it's on anymore but they
used to rebroadcast it and for years
we've talked about killed Tony and the
format and stuff and the same show is on
the same network.
So that's an little kind of creepy.
We've had everybody on the show.
Well listen,
you guys have been doing to kill Tony
for how many years now?
Over three years.
Everybody knows about it.
It's not a surprise and it's an
interesting format.
It's a funny format in limiting them to
a minute.
It like gives plenty of time for
awkwardness,
but it doesn't let it get completely out
of control and that's the part where
they messed up.
Like if they were,
if they were going to,
if they were going to take,
if they were going to do it,
that's they made a huge fundamental
mistake because they just made it so
that the comedian I guess can just ring
a bell at any point.
Which of course these New Yorkers,
you know,
I think it's hilarious to probably
interrupt seven seconds thinking,
oh,
I got one full.
Yo know what I mean?
Comedy just unstoppable.
Sure.
Anyway,
do you have a problem with New York
comedians?
And I mean,
I don't have a problem,
but like,
you know,
come on.
Anybody that knows what I'm talking
about.
No toss
because west coast,
what's going on?
What is this?
The elbows,
shoulders.
What are you doing here?
You know,
they're the best out there.
You mocking New York comedians now you
seem to be mocking them
west coast.
I just need to know to know where I
stand.
I'm going to be in a East Coast soon and
uh,
in November and I don't want any issues.
I just want to say that I was born in
New Jersey,
uh,
identify with east coast in some ways.
I actually think east coast comics are
nicer and less back stabby and more real
goal
to New York for a year.
Brian,
interesting.
You mean they're nice to you when
they're in town and want to do your job?
No,
no,
I just,
it's weird because out here it's like
you don't really,
you know,
there's a lot of fake shit out.
Well that is true.
This is a climate of fakeness with
auditions and you know,
meeting producers and all the bullshit
that comes with trying to be a working
actor in La.
It definitely tastes comedy.
You know,
there's a lot of people that you all
know that are like semi comedians that
do like a little stand up here and
there,
but they never record anything and the
occasionally go on the road.
But really what they do is they work as
actors and then they kinda like dabble
in comedy.
Right.
Those are all.
Those are weird fuckers because they're
not fully in and so the way they behave
and talk and think,
it's like just a little a shade off.
It's like a hybrid between an actor and
a comedian.
Yeah.
And they,
you know,
I don't know.
You don't want different.
They're different.
In New York it's like,
hey,
I did 17 sets tonight.
It's like,
oh,
well that's good.
Well how much do you.
How much value are you putting on those
17 sets?
So what?
I did one set at the comedy store and
know that this new two minutes works
exactly like this and like it's a higher
level.
I don't know man.
It depends on how much time you getting.
You know,
if you're doing 15 minutes of the comedy
store,
it's a,
it's a decent amount of time.
One of the problems with those short
sets is you're doing like five and seven
minute sets and there's a bunch of
people doing them.
Those are really hard to get anything
weird going.
They're really hard to express points of
view on things and like elaborate on
those points of view and have those
points of view tie in with other
ridiculous things that you noticed in
life.
You don't have enough time.
I love New York comedians.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm just hating on this show
specifically.
Like what I heard of this show that's
like the.
The people said whether kill Tony Rip
off is just a bunch of people ringing
the bell immediately and they don't even
let the poor comic even do their first
job without bashing them because
everything.
It's funny to interrupt course and so
like without that tension being built
over 60 seconds,
you don't know whether you like them,
whether you hate them,
you just know that this person on the
panels just being annoying.
Well when I,
when I do your show,
it's always this weird combination of
like try to be funny,
but this part of me that just wants to
give actual advice that's part of,
it's like a balance of the
two and then part of me wants to like
let people know like whatever you're
thinking is happening right now,
like whatever you think like this is
work,
this is,
this is a mess.
Like someone needs to explain this to
you,
that this is all a mess and like if you
just through people bombing one after
the other,
after the other,
after the other and you thought that the
show was just bombers row.
And then finally we go to the bucket one
last time and there was one,
you know,
this young Black Guy,
22 years old that's been doing it for
five years.
Fuck in destroying.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
he's a wrestler.
He just,
he just moved here from New York.
He's not a wrestler and he was more.
He was,
he went to high school with Jon Jones.
He was wrestling in high school.
I wrestled in college and now he's grown
up and he's a killer.
He's common 22 years old.
There's a lot of them out there.
Something shine.
David shine,
I think his name was now.
Do you think anybody bombs on purpose?
Is there anybody that goes out there and
purposely to kill Tony?
There's something.
There's been a few trolls.
I think people want to do good.
I mean,
yeah,
there's been a couple trolls,
but they haven't.
They don't last a second.
I immediately get rid of them.
We can't just come on and like plug
something.
You're done.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Exactly.
Ann Coulter,
let's bring this bitch home.
It's 4:30 tonight.
Everybody killed Tony on Mondays.
Comedy store alternating between main
room and belly room a Wednesday.
We're both at the desk.
Squad show at the comedy store.
Wednesday night 8:30 AM,
8:30.
Bert Kreischer.
Christina ask Steven is easy.
George Perez,
a bunch of people.
Yeah,
it's big ass show.
Big Show you Fox and then September
29th.
Tony and I are at the palace theater in
Columbus.
What?
I say 30th.
Oh yeah.
Thirty.
Don't go to the 29th,
we won't be there.
Go the 30th.
The 30th were at the palace theater in
Columbus and then the first we're at the
tower theater in Philadelphia.
That's it.
You red band on twitter.
Read Ben on instagram.
Tony motherfuck.
Enhance
touring like crazy.
Come see me.
Please.
Clip.com and they'll loony person we're
doing killed Tony at the come and take
it festival in November 18th.
Beautiful.
$20.
All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with Andreas
Antonopoulos
seal.